Borgers
Auf geht's ich habe gedacht bevor ich jetzt alleine rum basteln können wir auch nochmal stream machen
Und ich habe in letzter zeit so wenig gestreamt ich hoffe dass ich jetzt in nächster zeit wieder ein bisschen öfters auf die reihe krieg
Ich mach einfach doppelt doppel stream
Yes
Exzellente exzellente
Sampy drei monate excellent subscription das ist quasi drei monate ist es jetzt die frage ist das nur einmal
IQ plus plus für den chat oder ist es quasi immer einmal mehr also iq plus plus plus plus plus
Das ist glaube ich nur einmal sonst sonst platzt der kopf irgendwann
Willst du bisschen grinsen jetzt nicht ich habe gerade schon wieder genug gegrinst auf twitter alter
twitter deutschland hat schon mal wieder
empört alter meine güte
die sparkasse hat irgendeinen tweet abgesetzt
dass
man die ausgabe von
fragt mich ich krieg's gar nicht mehr zusammen dass man früher
umgangssprachlich die aus die gemischte ausgabe von 100 mark oder euro
umgangssprachlich früher als hausfrauen mischung bezeichnet hat oder waren sie wieder am start auf twitter haben sich aufgeregt
wie kann man so ein sexistisches wort heutzutage auf twitter posten
triggert
da ging es wieder rund hier
ich will manchmal echt nicht mehr auf dem planet sein wenn ich twitter
lese
oder hört ja
dabei war das offensichtlich so als fun fact zu erkennen ja
Weiß ich was daran jetzt so schlimm war
ja genau der tweet
was man kann sich echt über alles aufregen alter
meine fresse
hat man sonst echt gar nichts mehr zu tun
soll ich mich soll ich mich jedes mal drüber aufregen wenn einer einen witz macht wenn einer zu dick ist oder
irgendwas
hätte ich echt viel zu tun
ich könnte mich über irgendwelche geek
informatiker witze beschweren ich könnte mich über
shaming beschweren oder was auch immer aber ich denke mir einfach legt mich ist mir wurscht
ich weiß dass es nur ein fun fact deshalb die leute haben es trotzdem über übertrieben aufgeregt wieder auf twitter komplett unverständlich
Ja dass
der entschuldigungs reflex ist ja mittlerweile schon normal herr bei allem auch wenn eigentlich
gar nichts war und man mal wirklich ernsthaft die leute die sich darüber aufregen fragen müsste so nach dem motto
ihr habt ihr echt nichts besseres zu tun dann kommt dann wird erst mal riesen entschuldigung gefahren
Also ich habe kein problem einzugestehen wenn ich mist erzähle das würde ich auch immer so sagen im nachhinein so nach dem motto
er leute ich habe mit erzählt stimmt nicht oder
sonst wie wenn ich wirklich wirklich persönlich davon überzeugt sind dass ich irgendwie mal absolut kack erzählt habe ja
aber nicht für
random sache nur weil sich leute empören
Meinetwegen sollen sie machen sie wollen mag soll ich lieber bei der telekom ausbildung aber interaction
Also interaction sind die bmg six
Telekom also ich kann ich kann es ja natürlich aus eigener hand nicht sagen ich habe gehört die telekom ausbildung ist gar nicht so schlecht
interaction keine ahnung
es ist technisch beides bestimmt cool und ich könnte mir vorstellen
interaction ist
ist eine Nummer mehr Netzwerk- und Business-Backbone-Provider-mäßig orientiert als die Telekom.
Aber, ja.
Also ich persönlich würde zu Interaction, meiner Meinung nach, so rein Bauchgefühl-mäßig,
ich kann das jetzt nirgendwo festmachen, ganz ehrlich, man muss, man muss.
Also ich bin ja, ich bin ja wirklich dafür für Leben und Leben lassen und man muss es nicht übertreiben, ja.
Und wenn ich weiß, dass jemand anderes, also ich persönlich jetzt, wenn ich weiß, dass es jemand anderes echt nervt,
dann versuche ich mir Mühe zu geben, es nicht zu sehr zu übertreiben.
Aber man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass die ganze Welt sich auf Besonderheiten von einem einstellt.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht und damit muss man früher oder später klarkommen.
Dass einen nicht jeder komplett mit Samthandschuhen anfasst.
Wie wild, du bist ja sonst keine 30 plus, du kriegst ja, du kriegst ja Komplexe mit der, also das musst du,
du musst es aus reinem Selbstschutz schon irgendwann mal ein bisschen damit klarkommen,
wenn dich andere Leute nicht nur mit Samthandschuhen anfassen.
Anders, da geht es doch gar nicht.
Ja, ich sage nicht, dass man Leute ärgern soll, ja, ich, wie gesagt, mir tut es heute noch leid,
was, mir tut es heute noch leid.
Mit dem einen Azubi, der dann einen Nervenzusammenbruch hatte.
Ähm, genau.
Ich finde auch, es sollten durchaus, wenn man es weiß, alle ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen.
Das bin ich, bin ich sofort dabei.
Aber man kann sich trotzdem nicht immer darauf verlassen, dass die ganze Welt sich nach, nach den eigenen Gefühlen richtet.
Das passiert halt einfach nicht.
Ja, und natürlich nervt das sicherlich Leute.
Ich sage halt, gut, ich, also, ich, so wie ich hier im Stream immer rumlabere, muss man ja denken,
ich habe, äh, einen BMI.
45 plus und, äh, bin irgendwie 1,70 und wiege 180 Kilo.
Nein, nein, so ist es ja nicht.
Ich bin noch nicht mal dick genug.
Was heißt noch nicht mal dick genug?
Noch nicht mal dick genug, dass ich bei den Corona-Impfungen früher drankomme.
Also, es ist, es ist noch nicht kurz vorm Platzen, ja.
Es ist halt einfach ein bisschen viel.
Ja, und ich verstehe das, dass sich da Leute drüber aufregen und das sich zu Herzen nehmen.
Ich habe, ich habe früher auch mir sehr viel, sehr viel Sachen, äh, zu Herzen genommen,
wenn sich einer drüber beschwert hat, wenn ich irgendwie Mist gebaut habe.
Wobei ich so die, die äußerlichen Sachen mir nie sonderlich zu Herzen genommen habe.
Aber, ähm, äh, wenn einer, wenn einer gesagt hätte, ich hätte irgendwie was falsch gemacht,
was aber meiner Ansicht nach richtig war, da habe ich mich immer richtig drüber aufgeregt.
Naja, gut, das, also, ich finde nicht, dass man es darauf anlegen muss, ja.
Und die Leute sollen ein bisschen Rücksicht aufeinander nehmen, das ist okay.
Aber, und das ist, und das ist mein Punkt.
Also, wenn ich jetzt weiß, dass einer irgendwie,
irgendwelche Probleme hat, dann werde ich es ihm nicht direkt unter die Nase reiben, ja.
Also, insofern nehme ich, wenn ich die Leute kenne, schon Rücksicht drauf.
Aber, vieles weiß ich doch gar nicht.
Ja, und deswegen sage ich, allein schon aus ein bisschen Selbstschutz,
muss man darauf klarkommen, dass einen eben nicht die gesamte Welt mit Samthandschuhen anfasst.
Gar nicht mal unbedingt rein aus böser Absicht, die gibt es sicherlich auch.
Und es gibt genug Leute, die, ähm, die legen es drauf an,
andere Leute fertig zu machen, ja.
Aber es kommt auch oft genug vor,
dass man manche Sachen schlicht und ergreifend nicht weiß,
dass man irgendeinen doofen Spruch macht und man gar nicht weiß,
dass die Leute davon betroffen sind oder dass sie das aufregt.
Und...
Wie gesagt, allein schon aus Selbstschutz muss man ein bisschen klarkommen mit der Zeit.
So, schauen wir mal eine VM an.
Was hat das mit Ansible zu tun? Nix.
Poggers.
VM wird gestartet.
Was soll das denn wirklich mit Ansible zu tun haben?
Das war so eine, das war so eine typische Frage.
Das war so eine typische Frage. Das war so eine typische Frage.
Das war so eine typische Triggerfrage, wo wir gerade,
wo wir gerade dabei sind über Sachen, die einen aufregen.
Das ist so eine typische Triggerfrage.
Du weißt genau, dass das nix mit Ansible zu tun hat.
Du willst nicht schreiben, was soll das scheiß Stream?
Das hat ja nix mit Ansible zu tun.
Du stellst jetzt quasi diese Frage absichtlich so,
so nach dem Motto, was soll das scheiß?
Hast ja auch recht.
Ja.
Aber ich habe noch gar nicht angefangen.
So, machen wir erst mal Update, mal gucken, ob es irgendwas Neues gibt.
Genau, also was ich vorhabe, ich erzähle euch das mal kurz.
Rumpel, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich erzähle euch mal kurz was ich vorhabe.
Und zwar, ich bin ja gerade dabei,
alle meine Kisten, die ich so betreibe
und vor allem, wo ich nicht oft was drauf mache
und nach ein paar Wochen wieder vergessen habe,
wie die ausschauen,
die sind ein bisschen zu veransibilieren.
Da haben wir schon mal ein bisschen,
das ist ja, ich vergesse,
ich vergesse immer, dass es Red hat mittlerweile.
So, und ich bin da gerade dabei,
wie gesagt, meine ganzen Server,
die ich so habe, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen in Ansible Config reinzupacken.
Und eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen,
die muss ich noch machen.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht,
die können wir jetzt im Stream machen.
Und zwar, ihr wisst ja, dass ich übrigens,
wenn ihr was wissen wollt,
schreibt Edwublos in Chat dabei.
Ich gehe mal kurz in die andere VM
und starte mein Chat-Log-Tool,
dass ich nichts vergesse.
So, mal kurz ausmachen, wieder anmachen.
Alter, was?
Okay, das war jetzt aus dem letzten Stream.
Aber die Kombination ist ja mal mega old school.
Webmin und Bind als DNS.
Benutzt du für MQTT auch so ein
SIGBEE-to-MQTT?
Ja, ja, ja, mache ich.
Allerdings, der Stick hat mit SIGBEE-to-MQTT
nichts zu tun.
Der Stick, das ist ein ganz normaler
SIGBEE-Stick.
Und um das in Home Assistant zu integrieren,
gibt es verschiedene Varianten.
Du kannst entweder, warte mal,
mal gedrückt halten.
Du kannst entweder die offizielle
SIGBEE-Integration benutzen.
Du kannst SIGBEE-to-MQTT,
SIGBEE-to-MQTT verwenden.
Oder du kannst den DECONS,
heißt es, glaube ich, verwenden.
Gibt es auch als offizielles Add-on.
Ich persönlich bin mit MQTT am glücklichsten.
Könnt ihr mal, please, schreiben
in den Chat, mal gucken, ob mein Tool tut.
SDBA42, danke schön für den Sub.
Excellent, excellent.
Leute, das funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht?
Hm.
Okay, ich muss nochmal ausmachen.
Das ist kaputt.
Warum ist mein PP nicht da?
Warum ist mein PP-Board kaputt?
Wait a minute.
Das PP-Board...
Nee, ich wollte gerade sagen,
lul weh, Alter.
Okay, Moment, Moment, jetzt hier.
Add-Wobblords, lul weh.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Sehr gut.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay, da kann ich nämlich die Fragen
gleich nachher aufgreifen,
die ich übersehe.
Oh.
Ab wann gibt es dein Gamers-Only...
Schon wieder?
Was willst du alles mit Gamers-Only, Alter?
Jetzt willst du mir gleich wieder erzählen,
Eloatrix hat gesagt, ich würde mit ihm
Gamers-Only streamen oder irgendwie sowas.
Das warst du doch, oder?
Wie kommst du auf so Kram, Alter?
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Habe ich nicht gesehen.
Aber das ist nice.
Und wisst ihr, was ich viel nicer finden würde?
Wenn, ähm,
die endlich mal
ihre Windows-GUI-Geschichte
gefixt kriegen, dass man mit .NET
auch mal wieder ordentlich Windows-GUIs
gamieren kann.
So, wir sehen übrigens...
Oh.
Sehen wir doch vom letzten Mal auf.
Und warum habe ich das jetzt alles doppelt auf?
MonkaS.
Ah.
Wait a minute.
Warte mal.
IP add.
Welche IP hat das Ding?
39.
Okay, okay.
Dann mache ich das aus der anderen VM auf
und dann können wir anfangen.
Äh.
Ach nee, 5000 war es?
Nee.
Ach Mensch.
Oh nee, nee, nee.
Ah, yes.
Da ist es.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es.
Ja, hast recht.
Äh, gibt es ja theoretisch jetzt schon.
Mit, mit Elektron.
Weil es einfacher ist für die paar Server, die ich habe.
Und?
Und weil ich, äh, das damals Roland updaten wollte.
Geht das überhaupt noch?
Äh.
Ich glaube, ich habe nämlich das Token gelöscht.
Ja, ich, ich deppe, ich habe das Token gelöscht.
Heh.
Geht nicht mehr.
Mein Token ist nicht mehr.
SSH..
Key.
Und nochmal gucken, ob es noch funktioniert.
Gucken ob es noch funktioniert.
Name.
Keg.
Weight.
Äh.
Der kleine ist es.
Der 11er.
Ubuntu 20.
Komm, wir machen das neueste.
Bam.
Gucken ob es noch funktioniert.
Hm.
Hatten die kein 20.04 Image?
Moment, wie hieß der Kram nochmal?
Alter.
Alter, jetzt ist ja gut.
Lass mich doch einfach jetzt was machen, please.
CX-11?
Was, CX-11?
Ah, okay, der AP-Key scheint noch zu funktionieren.
Alles gut.
Excellent, excellent.
Also, den brauchen wir jetzt eh.
Zack.
Bam.
Wobei, nee, den brauchen wir nicht.
Ich hab doch schon längst einen Server erstellt.
Brauchen wir doch gar nicht.
Eliminator, danke schön für den Sub.
Moment, wir können ihn wieder löschen.
Gleich wieder löschen.
Ich hab doch schon im Vorfeld einen Server erstellt.
Delete.
ID.
So, bam, wieder weg.
Zack.
2-Head, ja.
Also, ähm, genau.
Also, ich wollte erzählen, was wir machen.
Und zwar, ich bin ja gerade dabei, wie gesagt, meine ganzen Server ein bisschen zu verautomatisieren,
dass ich die Dinger wieder aufbauen kann, wenn es abkackt.
Und eine Sache, die ich noch machen muss, das ist aktuell auf meinem 1,01-Ionor-Server drauf,
weil ich hab für den irgendwas gekauft.
Ich hab mir das Ding ja gekauft, weil ich testen wollte, ob die Dinger irgendwas taugen.
Und ich muss sagen, für 1 Euro im Monat ist das echt nicht schlecht.
So.
Also, und was ich mache, ist Folgendes.
Ich verwende ja hier daheim Home Assistant.
Kann euch leider das Dashboard immer noch nicht zeigen, weil zu sehr, zu sehr Leak alles, ja.
Aber das ist hier das Ding, was ich verwende.
Demo.
Moment.
Home Assistant Demo.
So ungefähr sieht das bei mir auch aus.
Wie in der Demo.
Ja, so plus, plus einen Plan hab ich hier nicht.
So, so sieht das bei mir auch umgepasst.
Ich hab oben dann auch Tabs.
So.
Und ich mach das so, dass ich erkennen kann, wo die Leute sind.
Nämlich hier das da mit der Map.
Ähm.
Gibt's verschiedene Möglichkeiten für Presence Detection.
Man kann das über Google machen, man kann's bei iCloud machen oder über Live360 oder sonst was.
Oder man kann das über...
OwnTracks machen, heißt das.
Das ist eine iOS-App.
Die schickt das Ganze über MQTT.
So.
Und was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist, ich habe auf meinem 1&1-Server einen MQTT-Broker drauf und von dort ruft sich das mein Home Assistant ab.
Warum ist das auf einem 1&1-Server?
Weil das muss im Internet sein.
Weil ansonsten kommt ja mein Handy nicht dran.
Die andere Variante, die ich ursprünglich mal ausprobiert hab, ist, dass man VPN aufbauen kann.
Das...
Ja, OwnTracks suckt.
Aber das ist das einzige, was es ist.
Das einzige, was es gibt in der Richtung.
Ich kenne nichts anderes.
Wenn du was anderes kennst, zeige ich dir.
Ich finde auch, dass OwnTracks suckt.
Geht mir auch auf den...
Also...
Das suckt und das geht mir auf den Sack.
So.
Und...
Du musst das halt über das Internet machen.
Ich hab's am Anfang probiert mit VPN.
Das Problem mit VPN ist, also VPN aufbauen und dann kann dann das Handy direkt an mein Home Assistant daheim die Location schicken.
Das Problem ist nur, dass das...
iOS typisch komplizierter ist, als man...
Als man denkt.
Denn...
Das VPN wird im Hintergrund bei iOS abgebaut.
Und das VPN ist nicht immer da, wenn das Location Tracking sein Update schicken will.
Also 90% der Requests gehen in die Hose.
Und im Prinzip kann es sein, dass die komplette Bahnfahrt nicht drauf ist.
Und das brauche ich ja zum Beispiel, wenn ich auf dem Heimweg bin im Sommer, dass ich meine Klimaanlage einschalten kann.
Wenn ich quasi...
Kurz vorm Arriven bin.
Ganzes Denglish Satz.
Ja.
So. Und deswegen wollte ich den Server jetzt mal automatisch aufbauen.
Und ich hab's bis heute auch noch nicht richtig gescheit gemacht.
Aktuell ist es so, dass es...
Ohne Zertifikate.
Also ohne Let's Encrypt Zertifikate.
Und alles.
Das ist einfach ein nackiger MQTT Server mit Authentifizierung davor.
Aber der Payload ist verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, es passt eigentlich schon.
Aber ich will es jetzt mal ordentlich machen.
Dann müssen wir erst mal gucken, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
So. So sieht's aus.
René P8, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Es irritiert mich übrigens immer noch, dass das Ganze jetzt Prime Gaming heißt.
Wie hieß das nicht früher einfach Twitch Prime und gut ist?
Warum haben sie das umbenannt?
War Jeff wieder langweilig, oder?
So, loggen wir uns mal kurz auf dem Server ein, den ich erstellt hab für das Vid.
Wo ist er?
Ach, die haben ernsthaft...
Ich sehe es gerade.
Ich mache das...
Ich habe das nämlich gerade zum Rebuilden.
Hetzner hat kein Ubuntu 2010 Image.
Echt nett.
Hey, wundere mich jetzt eigentlich.
Nee, tatsächlich.
Guck mal.
Stimmt.
Außerdem ist Jeff nicht mal bei Amazon.
Hast recht.
Warum haben die kein 20.10?
Wofür kann man MQTT eigentlich alles verwenden?
Ja, für alles, wo du so ein Message-Bus-Ding brauchst.
Ein Leichtgewicht.
Ein Leichtgewichtiges, ja.
Warum haben die kein 20.10?
Jeff?
Nein, der will irgendwelche wohltätigen Projekte machen oder so.
Was hat er erzählt, glaube ich.
Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass die 20.10 hatten.
Guck mal.
Das ist aber gar nicht...
Das ist einfach nicht aktuell.
Das ist...
Aber guck mal.
Ich habe es hier versucht gerade zu erstellen.
Mit 20.10 ging auch nicht.
Guckt hier.
Guckt hier mal.
Keck, wait.
Ich habe 20.10.
Guck hier.
Guck hier mal.
Keck, wait.
Ich habe 20.10 angegeben und das ging da nicht.
Aber ich bin mir...
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die das hatten.
Aber hier beim Rebuilden kann ich das nicht auswählen.
Haben die vielleicht irgendwelche Probleme und haben das deswegen rausgenommen?
Nein, oder?
Ich bin einfach zu blöd und habe es nicht gecheckt.
Kann natürlich auch sein.
Wahrscheinlich das.
Schreibt den Support.
Nein, Quatsch.
20.04 ist vollkommen okay.
So.
Bam.
Also.
Wie immer.
Das erste, was wir machen, ist...
Achso, wo habe ich denn mein Ansible-Kram?
Ufw.
Allow.
SSH.
Ufw.
Default.
Deny.
Ufw.
Enable.
So.
Firewall an.
Jetzt kann nichts mehr passieren.
Wir wissen ja, Firewall enabled, prinzipiell gleich...
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn das Programm kompiliert, dann geht es auch.
Dementsprechend kann mit Firewall an auch nichts mehr passieren.
Wo habe ich denn meinen ganzen Ansible-Kram hin?
Ah, hier.
Guck mal da.
Ich habe ernsthaft...
Leute, was ist denn mit mir los?
Ich habe ernsthaft mal einen Ordner gemacht, wo man Sachen wiederfindet.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Oh, ne.
Ich habe die Hälfte aber gelöscht.
Warum habe ich da so viel rausgeschmissen?
Wait a minute.
Wir hatten doch sogar Caddy-Installationen und sowas da alles schon drin.
Ich habe keinen Bock, das nochmal neu zu machen.
Gut, es war nicht so kompliziert.
Ich verwende Mosquito, weil das das Einzige ist, was dabei ist und was man easy konfigurieren
kann.
Also easy in Anführungsstrichen konfigurieren kann.
Hm.
Wo ist mein Ansible-Zeug, mein Ansible-Config hin?
Excellent.
Habe ich das hier gelöscht?
Ha!
Excellent.
Shit.
FTV, Alter.
Nice.
Da ist nämlich der ganze Kram noch drin, das brauche ich gleich wieder.
Warum?
Ja, okay.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum ich den Kram, warum ich den Kram rausgeschmissen habe,
aber okay.
Ähm.
Ja.
Ja, warte mal.
Ich will jetzt keinen Mist machen.
Konnte man.
Nicht einfach Reset-Hard sagen und dann geht es auf den letzten Commit.
Ich bin mir jetzt aber nicht so sicher.
Ich.
Also in dem Fall, ob ich Commit habe.
Bäm.
Jetzt ist die Frage.
Ist es da oder nicht?
Bäm.
Da ist wieder alles.
Alles klar.
So.
Also.
Wunderbar.
Der ganze Krempel ist da.
Ansible.
Ja, dann lassen wir das doch gleich mal laufen.
Machen wir Visual Studio Code auf.
Dann lassen wir die Basic Install, lassen wir doch schon mit Ansible machen.
Alles, was wir schon haben.
Ne, nicht Test.
Äh.
Das Ding habe ich gerade.
Test.
SAV.
Custom Domain.
Remote User Route.
Okay.
Also was machen wir?
Wir machen ein Update.
Install Telnet Git.
Äh.
Allow UFW.
Allow HTTP.
Machen wir das gleich.
Das lassen wir erst mal weg.
Bin mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Ob ich das haben will.
So.
Da wird Kadi installiert.
Kadi Repo.
Reverse Proxy.
Äh.
Das mache ich auch mal raus.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob man das brauchen.
Okay.
.Net.
Das ganze .Net Zeug.
So.
.Net Zeug.
Das kann weg.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ja, ja.
Ne, das kann weg.
Das ganze .Net Zeug war für den Preisschamp.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Aber ich kann schon mal mein Ensemble Kram laufen lassen.
Gucken wir mal.
SAV, habe ich das Teil genannt.
So, Ansible
mal ausführen.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal? Einfach Hosts,
Inventory, Hosts
und dann Base-Yaml
ausführen, okay.
Also von der Idee her, sollte der sich
jetzt auf dem Server einloggen,
alles konfigurieren, so dass ich dann
den Kram weitermachen
kann und gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Der sollte mir das Ding updaten,
der sollte mir Basic-Tools
drauf installieren.
Musik ist ein Ticken
laut, oder? Ein Stückchen
leiser
mache ich mal. So, der sollte
mir also als Update Basic-Tools installieren,
SSH erlauben, UFW
einschalten und Kadi als
Reverse-Box installieren. Also ich habe mir das
gedacht, wir machen folgendes auf den Server drauf.
Wie gesagt, mein Ziel ist am Ende,
dass wir einen MQTT-Server
haben, plus Let's Encrypt.
The fuck?
Ah, ich habe meinen Numplog nicht
an. Plus Let's Encrypt.
So, dann brauchen
wir einen Prometheus-Node-Exporter
drauf, weil ich mir
gerne Crafts angucke
und dann habe ich auch gleich
einen Endpunkt, um die Gültigkeit
vom Zertifikat zu testen.
Soweit die
Idee. Also das heißt, wir
brauchen dann einen Reverse-Proxy.
Proxy, das machen wir mit
Kadi, das ist dann am einfachsten.
Das sind zwei Zeilen Config.
Läuft der Broker
bei dir durchgängig? Musst du ihn regelmäßig neu starten?
Der läuft durchgängig.
Den muss ich nur neu starten,
wenn sich das Zertifikat
updatet. Da muss ich auch mal gucken, wie man das macht.
So, wir brauchen also
einen Reverse-Proxy. Wir brauchen
einen MQTT-Server.
Das kann ich mir nicht schreiben.
Mosquito.
Mittlerweile weiß ich, wie man schreibt.
Ja, und die Zertifikate
bin ich mir nicht sicher,
ob wir die Zerts mit Kadi
oder mit Zertbot machen.
Der Vorteil an Zertbot ist,
der kann beispielsweise, nachdem man
ein Zertifikat aktualisiert hat,
Dienste neu starten.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob das
Sinn ergibt.
Mir wäre es eigentlich lieber, ich bräuchte kein Zertbot,
sondern einfach nur die zwei Sachen.
Snap. Ne.
Kein Snap.
Snap suckt.
So, hat er es jetzt geschafft?
Changed. Fünf. Nice.
Excellent.
So, also, jetzt sollte der Server frisch
aufgebaut sein. Es sollte beispielsweise
ein H-Top drauf sein. Es sollte ein Git
drauf sein. Und es sollte
auch sowas wie Nload drauf sein.
Sehr gut. Nice.
Okay. Also, basic
basic
Ansible
Config hat funktioniert.
Ups, ich hab mich vertippt.
Ich wollte das auf Desktop 3 schieben.
So, ist Kadi installiert?
Jawohl. Sehr gut.
Status
Nice, nice, nice. Okay.
Das hat funktioniert. Also, die basic
Sachen gehen schon mal.
Das ist nice. Da muss ich das schon mal
nicht machen. So, und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen,
wie kriege ich es gebacken, dass
ich den ganzen
Kram hier drauf kriege, sodass es dann
möglichst easy in Ansible umzusetzen
ist und dass ich ein gültiges Zertifikat
kriege.
Stänzebar. Dankeschön für den Sub. Exquisite
Subscription. Kann man Kadi mit Traffic
vergleichen? Leute, ihr müsst unbedingt, wenn ihr was wisst,
AdWoblos davor machen, weil ansonsten
übersehe ich den Kram. Ich habe nämlich hier
extra so ein Ding
mitlaufen, was
alles an mich mitlockt, dass ich es nicht übersehe.
Ja, du kannst Kadi ein bisschen mit Traffic
vergleichen, nur mit dem
Unterschied, dass die Kadi-Config viel, viel
einfacher ist. Traffic
kann potenziell Build-in
mehr, aber die Config ist
eklig.
Ich warte ja noch drauf, dass irgendwann mal
einer was baut, wo die Config easy ist,
alle möglichen Sachen integriert
hat und
was mit allem
sich auch gut integrieren lässt.
Das ist also
Tom Schinelli, das ist nur bei mir so.
Das habe ich mir gebastelt, also
das ist bei anderen nicht so, aber du siehst hier,
wenn du den Namen von jemandem schreibst,
dann kriegt er das halt so gehighlighted.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Und wenn du neu bist,
eine Sache,
was man prinzipiell ja allen empfehlen muss,
die neu auf Twitch sind, siehst du
siehst du dieses
Emote hier bei dir
oder steht hier Pause-Champ bei dir?
Du siehst das?
Okay, dann hast du schon passendes Add-on installiert.
Gut, weil das ist das Allerwichtigste.
FFZ installieren mit Better Twitch TV
Extension.
Ohne ist Twitch nicht
nicht benutzbar.
So, geupdatet hat er auch. Jetzt muss ich ja gar keine
Basics mehr machen.
Da steht Pause-Champ. Ja, dann brauchst
du unbedingt das hier.
Falls du Chrome hast, Firefox geht auch.
Du brauchst unbedingt den da
und dieses Add-on-Pack.
Äh, Moment.
Ich bin verwirrt. Falsch rum.
Du brauchst dieses Add-on
und dann das Better Twitch TV Add-on-Pack.
Oder Better Twitch TV direkt.
Es ist so ein bisschen Glaubensfrage,
ob man FFZ verwendet
oder Better Twitch TV.
Unterm Strich machen beide Add-ons das
Gleiche. Gibt
mehr Emotes und der Chat ist einfacher zu lesen.
Das ist das Beste.
Ich lasse mich vom Chat permanent ablenken.
Das ist normal.
Für Presence Detection mit meinem
iPhone will ich die einsetzen.
Beziehungsweise setze ich die schon ein, aber ich will sie jetzt mal
veransibilisieren,
dass ich es benutzen kann.
Okay, also, apt install
install mosquito
mosquito clients
zum ausprobieren.
So, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Das muss ich gleich reinmachen
in Installer.
Genau, das muss ich gleich
in Installer reinmachen, weil sonst vergesse ich das garantiert.
Alles latest.
Ja, ja, latest passt.
Erstmal direkt anmachen.
Ja, ich würde, aber denk dran,
bevor du UFW anmachst,
mach den hier, ne?
UFW allow SSH, ansonsten sperrst du dich
selbst aus. Das warnt
dich auch nochmal vorher.
Wie würdest du die Anwesenheit mit Android umsetzen?
Mit Android würde ich
wahrscheinlich
einfach einen Tasker
Task machen, der meine GPS
Dinger,
in irgendeinem Format, wo ich sie verarbeiten kann,
wohin schickt. Da gibt es, glaube ich, bessere
Varianten unter Android als
OwnTracks. OwnTracks suckt ein bisschen.
Habe ich das jetzt eigentlich installiert
oder habe ich vorher abgebrochen?
Also installieren wir
mosquito mosquito clients.
Dann, nachdem man installiert hat,
Systemctl enable.
Hallo?
Okay.
Meinetwegen. So, wie mache ich das in
Ansible?
State enabled.
Moment. Ähm.
State, state, state.
Konnte man das nicht direkt?
Ansible
enable service.
Kann man das gleich mit dem Installer machen?
Okay, dass das, das
funktioniert. Kann man das
nicht mit dem Installer machen?
Dass man gleich sagen kann, wie enabled
oder sowas?
Nee, anscheinend nicht. Okay, das heißt, das braucht man nochmal hinten drauf.
Ähm.
Zack.
Ja, ja.
Enabled.
Ähm. Äh, nee, warte mal.
Enabled. Ah, nein, nein, nein. Das stimmt ja gar nicht, was ich mache.
Warte mal, was kopiere ich mir denn hier für ein Crap?
Äh.
Enable.
Enabled. Hier, das da brauche ich.
Cagweight.
So, das da.
Enabled. Yes.
Wunderbar. Gut.
So.
Die Firewall
machen wir davor,
dass das eingeschaltet wird,
bevor ich irgendwelche Services installiere.
Das ist, glaube ich, sinnvoller.
Theoretisch können wir die Firewall sogar ganz am Anfang machen.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Wir machen die Firewall einfach ganz am Anfang.
Okay. Also, jetzt muss ich erstmal selbst gucken,
wie das, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Also, ich habe den Kram installiert. Enabled.
Ha. Und jetzt ist die große
Preisfrage. Wie mache ich das mit den Zertifikaten?
ETC.
Wir, wir, wir, wir machen uns mal,
wir machen uns mal, wir lassen uns mal ein Zertifikat
ausstellen über Cudi.
Und dann gucken wir, ob wir das irgendwie da reinbekommen.
Weil ich habe, ehrlich gesagt, keinen Bock
auf Zertbot.
Ich habe vorher ein ganz gutes How-To gefunden
bei DigitalOcean.
Aber das mit Zertbot hat mir nicht gefallen,
wie die das vorgeschlagen haben.
Die machen das nämlich so, das ist auch eine Sache,
an die habe ich auch am Anfang gedacht.
Ähm, und zwar,
die installieren den ganzen Kram,
bla bla bla, und dann machen sie einen Hook.
Machen sie einen Hook
bei, äh, beim Zertbot.
Und immer, wenn das Zertifikat
neu erstellt wurde, starten sie den Zertbot.
Starten sie den Service neu.
Aber das brauche ich wahrscheinlich nicht.
Moment, der Zertbot kommt bei Ubuntu über Snap?
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Was?
Äh, wirklich?
Das ist doch, das ist doch, warum?
Das steht natürlich
nicht dabei.
Oh, ich habe mich verklickt.
Haha, ich wollte den anderen
Timeout null.
Hahaha, ups.
Haha, da war ich
unbandig wieder. Haha.
Marcel
SH, lol.
Oh, jetzt wird der richtige
Timeouted.
Gag Wait, ja.
Aimed.
NA Aimed.
Nee, das war einfach Input-Lag im Chat.
Der Karlsson,
17 Monate am Start.
Massive, Alter. 17 Monate.
Du bist ja schon ewig am Start.
Wo ist denn hier Hyper-Subscription?
Hier.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich sehe dich nicht oft im Chat, aber trotzdem nice,
dass du so lange schon am Start bist.
Zertbot Instructions.
Na.
Warum? Ich will das nicht über Snap.
Snap ist übelster Crap.
Was ist mit den Ubuntu-Leuten los,
Alter? Mit den Ju-Jubantu-Leuten.
Ja, über App installiert er aber auch einen Snap.
Ist ja auch egal. Ich hoffe, wir brauchen das gar nicht.
Okay. Ähm.
Sidetracked.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Etc. Kadi.
Kadi-File.
Kadi ist wirklich easy as fuck.
Also wenn ihr ne Reverse-Proxy braucht,
ihr könnt eigentlich da nix falsch machen mit Kadi.
So. Ähm.
Also. Ups.
Die Config ist auch total einfach.
Man nimmt einfach die Domain, wo das ganze
erreichbar sein soll.
Ich bau nen MQTT-Server,
der nen gültiges Zertifikat hat, was ich für
Location-Tracking für mein iPhone
verwenden kann. Allerdings nicht den Server.
Ich werd hier keine GPS-Koordinaten
leaken gleich.
Äh. Deutlich einfacher als Nginx.
Wobei Nginx geht auch. Also im Vergleich zu
Apache ist alles einfach.
Ähm. Aber Kadi ist wirklich easy.
Also für nen Zertifikat.
Guck mal. Also alles, was du
machen musst für nen Zertifikat.
Nginx kann ja glaube ich standardmäßig gar kein Let's Encrypt.
Du musst es entweder über nen CertPod machen
oder irgendein anderes Skript. Oder über Docker.
Wo dann wiederum ne CertPod mit verpackt ist.
So. Du sagst einfach Test
Server. So. Das ist die Domain.
Die hab ich schon umgebogen im DNS.
Port 443. Das kannst du dir
by the way alles sparen.
Hier rein zu schreiben. Da geht er automatisch
von aus. Aber
ähm. Ich find's besser, wenn man
das angibt. So.
Okay.
Cmccl. Restart Kadi.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das mit den
Zertifikaten funktioniert
hat. Okay.
Er macht Zertifikat-Zeug. Probieren wir das mal
aus. Test SAV.
Geht nicht. Achso.
Ja. Warum geht's wohl nicht
Leute? Wer hat
aufgepasst? Warum geht's nicht?
Ist eigentlich relativ klar.
Firewall. Korrekt.
Allow HTTPS.
Bam.
Test SAV.
Achso.
HTTPS.
Äh.
Wait. Ich hab Kadi
schon neu gestartet.
Noch mal neu starten
muss ich den doch nicht.
Was hab ich verkeh-
Normalerweise ist das alles, was man machen muss.
Ich hab aber irgendwas vergessen.
Da fehlt- Nee. Da fehlt
eigentlich
nix in der Kadi-Conf.
Ach stimmt. Ich mach ja hier
gar kein DNS-Challenge.
Ah. Ja. Das geht
nicht. Ich muss Port 80 erlauben.
Ich muss Port 80 erlauben.
Sonst geht's nicht.
Weil. Ich mach normalerweise
den ganzen Kram über DNS-Challenge.
Da brauchst du keinen Port frei.
Aber hier ist es ja ganz normal ein HTTP-Challenge,
wo Let's Encrypt nachguckt,
ob ne Textdatei rumliegt. So.
Und das geht natürlich nur, wenn Port 80 frei ist.
Schreibt ihr irgendeinen Log?
Nee. Den Log gibt's nicht.
So. Schauen wir mal, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Ah. Yes.
Jetzt funktioniert's, Leute.
Ja. Wir werden nicht rate-limited.
Also wenn ihr auf die Uhr geht, sollte das eigentlich auch sein.
Ich hab's gut gesehen.
By the way, die Seite ist absichtlich so shabby.
Irgendjemand bei Kani hat sich gedacht, das ist ne gute Idee.
Ich bin besoffen.
Ok.
Wir müssen übrigens beide, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
UFW, SSH erlauben.
HTTP erlauben.
Und HTTPS erlauben.
Kann man UFW,
Can man mehrere
Firewall-Regeln auf einmal machen?
Alternativ
Könnt ihr einfach euren Kopf ein bisschen schräg machen
Dann ist es wieder gerade
Ah man kann Port Ranges machen
Das will ich aber nicht
Ich will ja nur zwei Sachen
Das geht anscheinend nicht
Ich kann da doch bestimmt eine Liste angeben
Oder?
Ich kann doch bestimmt machen
Port HTTP
Und HTTPS
Werden wir gleich sehen ob das funktioniert
Wenn ich es dann ausprobiere
Jemand eine Ahnung ob das geht?
Es ist nicht in den Beispielen drin
Also
Warum nicht als Docker Container
Ja das ist die andere Alternative
Aber nachdem das mit Docker
Und UFW und so nicht richtig funktioniert
Und ich den Kram nur einmal hinstellen muss
Ich hab es mir überlegt
Ob ich nicht ein Docker Compose File mache
Aber ganz im Ernst
So ist auch nicht
Ich kann gar nicht sagen was davon jetzt besser ist
In dem Fall gefällt mir die Variante
Also die Ansible Variante besser
Außerdem Docker ist out
Die coolen Leute verwenden Potman
Naja zum Glück nicht
Umso weniger Red hat umso besser
Schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert
Leute by the way
Ich hab gehört angeblich
Ich weiß den Account nicht
Und wenn ich den Account wüsste würde ich ihn euch nicht sagen
Mein Chef streamt angeblich
Jetzt auch auf Twitch
Hat er letztens erzählt
Ich weiß aber weder welche Games
Noch sonst was
Ich will den Account auch gar nicht wissen
Nicht dass ich das aus Versehen mal irgendwie erzähle
Oder da im Chat schreibe
Und der dann was erzählt
Und dann mal wieder Sachen liegt
Und
Ne
Hurray
Wie gesagt ich weiß den Account gar nicht
Ok also Moment
Das funktioniert jetzt
Excellent
So hier Leute
Port
Wunderbar
Hier
Huge Certificate
UFW Port 80
Ja das müsste ja das gleiche sein im Endeffekt
Was ich hier gemacht hab
Also was du geschrieben hast
Ist die
Array
Die YAML Array Schreibweise
Und das hier müsste die Jason Schreibweise sein
Die müsste eigentlich auch gehen
Vermute ich mal
Werden wir dann sehen
Aber jetzt muss ich den ganzen Kram erstmal zum Laufen bekommen
Ähm
Ok also ich hab ne Moskito installiert
Läuft der denn schon
Jop
So
Was ist denn das
TMP DLT Cannot Be Opened
Ach scheiß drauf
Ich mein ey so lange wir hier sind kann es nicht laufen
Ach scheiß drauf ich mein ey so lange wir hier sind kann es nicht laufen
So lange das ordentlich runn das ist mir egal
Ok also
Wir haben nen Webserver
Wir haben ein gültiges Zertifikat
Wir haben ne Moskito installiert
Also MQTT Server
Äh jetzt brauch ich noch ein Prometheus Node Exporter
Für nice crafts
Kann ich euch ja gleich zeigen wie man das einrichtet
Ähm
Dann machen wir mal ein schönes Grafana Dashboard
Sieht dann immer schick aus
Äh Ex...
Ne das heißt Prometheus Node Exporter
In welcher Hierarchie
Was ist das schon
Ach das ist da
Ach Moment hab ich das vielleicht in der Basic Install drinne
Ah Big Brain Leute
In welcher Hierarchie ist dein Chef Chef
Äh
Das
Ist glaub ich die erste Management Ebene
CEO
Genau
Vorstandsvorsitzender
Nein das ist die erste
Ich glaub das ist die erste Management Ebene
Also quasi so eine Art Teamleiter
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken ob es ist Teamleiter
Gruppenleiter oder irgendwie anders nennen
Das ändert sich bei uns alle halbe Jahr mal
Ich sag einfach immer mal Teamleiter
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit
Ist eh so eine lustige Geschichte
Die sind wirklich laufend dabei
Die haben auch irgendwelche Beratungsleute
Und so am Start
Ähm sind laufend dabei
Irgendwelche Dinger
Umzustrukturieren und umzudefinieren
Und umzuprozessen und sonstwas
Die beste Reaktion bei uns auf der Arbeit
Wenn jemand ankommt und sagt
Leute es gibt jetzt ein ganz neues wichtiges Verfahren
Prozess 578.000
Und das ist so
Und mit Liste und Checklist und sonstwas
Das erste was man machen muss ist
Nichts
Einfach
Mal 3 Monate warten
Und gucken ob man jemals wieder was von hört
Außen stehen gut
Dass man von 80% der Sachen nie wieder was hört
Und das ist unglaublich wie oft das hilft
Genau
Keeper XY Leute
Man muss einfach erstmal
Man muss einfach erstmal nichts machen
Einfach erstmal abwarten
Und es gibt auch ganz viele Dinger bei uns
Die dann erstmal komplett im Sand verlaufen
Die sind jetzt ganz wichtig und müssen jetzt sofort gemacht werden
Und jeder muss sich dran halten
Und irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später hört man dann
Der Typ der das damals angekündigt hat
Ist jetzt nicht mehr auf dieser Position
Wir hatten auch letztens sowas
Da sollten wir an jedes Ticket
An jedes Ticket
Sollte irgendwie so ein spezielles
Wie nenne ich das jetzt am besten
Ohne es genau zu verraten
So ein spezielles Ticket sollte verknüpft werden
Jedes mal
Sollte das verknüpft sein
Mit dem eigentlichen Ticket
Und der Typ der das angeleitet hat
Ist jetzt nicht mehr auf dieser Position
Das ist so geil
Das geht bei uns immer
Ganz so koordiniert zur Sache
Und dann
Widersprechen sie sich auch immer
Auf der einen Seite kommen sie an
Hey wir wollen das jetzt super
Statisch
Und prozessorientiert
Und nach
Dings Ablauf genormt
Und sonst was
Und auf der anderen Seite sagen sie
Leute wir müssen agil sein
Die Tickets müssen immer noch verknüpft sein
Aber das war halt witzig
Das hat sich nicht erledigt
Das ist immer noch so
Aber der Typ ist nicht mehr da
Der es mit eingeführt hat
Weiß nicht da hat er kein Bock mehr drauf
Irgendwie
Die brauchen die Hilfe von Peter Agilet
Und das widerspricht sich total
Du kannst nicht auf der einen Seite
Alles komplett geregelt haben wollen
Und dann auf der anderen Seite agil sein
Entscheidet
Entscheidet euch für eins
Das eine mit dem anderen
Zusammen das funktioniert nicht
Und was auch immer witzig ist
Ich komme jetzt voll ins labern
Aber was auch lustig ist
Sie erzählen manchmal so
Hey Leute Stabilität
Ist das
Allerwichtigste
So
Als nächstes kommt
Übrigens
Das geht hier alles nicht schnell genug
Das muss alles
Schneller gehen
Okay das heißt wir wollen jetzt Stabilität und Schnelligkeit
Okay ist ja noch machbar
Ist ja noch machbar
Das kommt als drittes
Und das ganze Zeug ist zu teuer
So das heißt
Man möchte
Günstig
Das passt aber nicht zusammen
Also
Es gibt drei Sachen die gehen nicht zusammen
Stabil
Schnell
Und günstig
Das geht nicht
Du kannst stabil und schnell machen
Dann wird es garantiert nicht günstig
Ja
Du kannst stabil und günstig machen
Dann wird es garantiert nicht stabil
Du kannst keine Ahnung
Stabil und günstig machen
Dann wird es nicht schnell
Das geht alles nicht in Kombination
Wo ich meine Domains
Miete bei Pogban
Aber die empfehle ich nicht
Die waren einfach nur die billigsten
Das ist bei uns so paradox
Irgendwie
Das ist voll paradox
Bei uns so
Wir machen das andere
Aber da habe ich mich schon gewöhnt
Das ist unser Style
Hast du schon eine Emoji Domain
Nein habe ich nicht
So also weiter
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
Node Exporter ist am Start
So bei der Gelegenheit
Dann machen wir doch mal den Node Exporter
Public verfügbar
So jetzt kann ich euch mal zeigen
Wie easy das mit Cudi ist
Den Node Exporter public verfügbar zu machen
TestSRVMAU.House
So da läuft ja aktuell
Dieser Testserver drauf den wollen wir nicht
Wir wollen eigentlich nichts anderes
Wie alles was da rein kommt
Reverse
Reverse Proxy
Auf
Den Port
Vom
Prometheus
Ich glaube das ist es
So und nun wollen wir noch
Ein
Basic Auth davor machen
So dass das nicht jeder aufrufen kann
Was spielst du eigentlich aktuell für Spiele
Tja also ich habe in letzter Zeit wieder
Relativ viel Battlefield 3 gespielt
Mal gucken ob da jetzt Leute auf dem Server sind nebenbei
Ich werde das nicht spielen interessiert mich nur mal
Ist wahrscheinlich wieder Rip Venice komplett dead
Ich spiel ab und zu
Noch ein bisschen Path of Exile ansonsten
Ich warte händeringend drauf
Dass mal irgendwie ein geiles Sucht Game
Wieder kommt
Aber
Okay Dead Game
Das ist wieder richtig
Geiles Sucht Game kommt
Aber kommt ja nix
So by the way mehr muss man nicht machen für Kadi Reverse Proxy
Inklusive Automatisch SSL
Eigentlich richtig nice
So aber wir machen noch Basic Auth
Kadi Hash Passwort
So jetzt muss ich mir ein Passwort ausdenken
Was ihr nicht erraten könnt
So Bäm
Gehashtes Passwort
So und jetzt weiß ich gar nicht
Wie man das reinschreibt
So Basic Auth
Bob
Nicht Bob
Basic Auth
Lolwe
Ist jetzt das richtige was ich hier genommen hab
Oder war das das hier
Ne das war das richtige
Bin drin nice Chat sehr gut
Excellent Excellent ich hab nicht immer reloadet
Aber der Chat ist schon drin ne
Hetzner Cloud
Ich wechsel immer zwischen
Nürnberg und Falkenstein ab
Ich hab aktuell Server in allen 3 RZs
Dass ich immer schön andere IPs kriege
So äh
Basic Auth
Zack
Ich glaub man braucht das hier gar nicht
Dann gilt's für alles
Bin ich mir aber gar nicht so sicher
Ich glaub man braucht das gar nicht
So Kadi Restart
So und wenn ihr jetzt alles richtig gemacht habt
Dann fragt mich Kadi
Nach einem Passwort
Bäm
Und ich guck jetzt mal ob das funktioniert
Äh was hab ich
Was hatte ich nochmal für nen User
Lolwe
So ein Passwort wisst ihr nicht
Save
Äh Matrix
Äh
Warte mal
Was ist denn der Prometheus Default Port
Hab ich mich vertippt
Oh
Moment
Netztat
Ach 9
Das ist ja gar nicht der Node Exporter
Ah ja fast
Aber eins muss man sagen
Ich weiß nicht ob der Engine X
Äh ich sag mal der Engine X Fan noch da ist
Äh
Das ist einfacher oder
Das musste
Muss zugeben
Deswegen mag ich den Kram auch
Auf jetzt Bäm
Da sind meine Prometheus Matrix
Sehr schön
Die brauchen wir schon mal
Excellent Prometheus Matrix
Ich hab dich erfolgreich von Kadi überzeugt Excellent
Zum Beispiel ist DNS Authentifizierung für Let's Encrypt nicht eingebaut
Du brauchst irgendwelche komischen Plugins
Und
Äh
Ich weiß nicht
Ich hatte letztens auch ein paar Sachen die gingen mit Kadi nicht gescheit
Also
Wenn man einfach nen Basic Web Server braucht
Also ne
Wenn man das braucht was es kann ist gut
Wenns da drüber hinaus geht kommt man an
Entweder Traffic wenn man irgendwas Docker Heavy hat
Oder ansonsten so der Klassiker
Äh Engine X für alles auch trotzdem nicht vorbei
Musstest du den 9001 in UFW freischalten
Nein den muss ich nicht freischalten
Weil
Ich ja Reverse Proxy
Reverse Proxy von dieser Domain
Auf intern 911
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon
Mit Basic Auth davor
Also sprich ihr könnt da jetzt nicht drauf zugreifen
Und das ist ziemlich easy
So wollen wir uns schnell mal ein Dashboard machen
Komm wir machen uns mal schnell Poggers Dashboard
Einfach weil es funktioniert
Namekartier Compose
Wir machen uns Massive Massive Dashboard
Für ähm
Äh
Sample Grafana
Es geht schnell
Compose
Haben die da irgendein Basic
Äh genau
Ne das ist alles Müll
Das stimmt nicht
Ja das da ist schon mal gut
Das brauchen wir
Latest
Prometheus bla bla bla
Volumes
Jawoll Data alles klar
Brauch mal Commands
Wobei ich kann das doch einfach kopieren was ich schon fertig hab
Lol weh warum bin ich denn
Moment ich kopier einfach das was ich schon hab
Da waren wir exzellent
Exzellent exzellent äh
Was bedeutet Reverse Proxy
Naja also
Was ein Proxy macht
Weißt du wahrscheinlich
Also wenn du ein Proxy fragt stellvertretend
Für dich Internetseiten an
Das heißt du kannst über den Proxy ins Internet gehen
Im Reverse Proxy ist das umgedreht
Das Internet geht über den Proxy zu dir
Naja über einen normalen Proxy
Also quasi über einen Forward Proxy
Ich weiß nicht ob man das so nennt
Aber ich nenn's jetzt einfach mal so
Gehst du auf den Proxy
Der Proxy führt dich ins Internet
Und dann wieder zurück und er gibt dir die Seite
Und im Reverse Proxy ist umgedreht
Du gehst auf den Internet geht auf den Proxy
Und kommt damit zu dir
Äh ich bin grad irgendwie grad nicht in der Lage
Das richtig zu schreiben
Ah Commands brauchen wir alles nett
Prometheus und jetzt brauchen wir noch das Grafana Ding
Exzellent
Alles klar
Und dann können wir das starten
Und dann machen wir ein huge massive nice dashboard
Das braucht man glaub ich auch alles nicht
Naja alles gut
Perfekt links
Genau das leitet alles was bei dem Port 443 reinkommt
Auf die äh
Auf das richtige weiter
So ich hoffe ich hab jetzt das Docker Compose richtig gemacht
Ne das ist schonmal falsch was ich hier gemacht hab
Schau mal verkehrt
So
Und ich glaub man muss auch irgendwie oben ins Docker Compose
Was anderes reinschreiben oder bin ich jetzt verwirrt
Docker Compose
Ab
Ne hä musst du aber nicht oben Versionen und sowas
Noch reinschreiben normalerweise
Warum geht denn das jetzt
Warum ist das jetzt neu dass das geht
Keck wait
Wait a minute
Was hab ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht
Wisst ihr was wir machen
Wir machen einfach Easy Mode
Wir machen Easy Mode
Network
Network Host 0
Ich will einfach nur ein Dashboard haben
Ich will mich jetzt nicht zu lange damit
Zu lange damit beschäftigen
Hab ich Subs übersehen
Eigentlich schon für die Subs
Äh
Ich hab
Creator Dashboard
Ich hab nix gesehen
Wen hab ich denn übersehen wieder
Ich hab doch gar keinen übersehen
Tom Schinelli Dankeschön 24 Minute
Hab ich nicht gesehen sorry
Ja manchmal bin ich so am
Am Hackerman machen
Massive Subscriptions
Ok also was äh
Hier Network Host Network Host
Up
Was Moment wie
Alter
Wie waren das jetzt
Networking Host Use Host
Ach Network Mode ist es
Network Mode
Network
Mode
Gucken jetzt Wim Trick Wim Trick Punkt drücken
Bam
Was hab ich jetzt
Verwirrt
Ne ist nicht Networking Mode
Networking
Ok wir machen das Ding mal richtig
Irgendwas stimmt mit dem Pfeil nicht
Gut ähm
Ich brauch so ein Mini-Exempel
Genau
Weiß ich was der für Schmerzen hat Alter
Kann man das auf gleicher
Jawoll
Ab
Ah sieht schon besser aus
Äh 08 Max 07 5 Monat
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ok äh Verzeichnis nicht vorhanden
Weil
Keine Prometheus Config
Ja gut das weiß ich
Aber ich darf jetzt da nicht rein
Ernsthaft
Alter Bam
Data Prometheus
Ich brauch irgendeine easy Prometheus Config
Wim
Punkt
Dann sollte es eigentlich funktionieren
Genau hier
Prometheus Jamel
So und dann haben wir mal
Nices Dashboard
Passte
So Blablabla
Scrap Intervall 100 Ok
Targets
Äh
Test SAV Punkt
Haus
Port
Port 443
Achso
Wie mach ich
Wie mach man Prometheus
Ah ne da muss ich jetzt mein Passwort im Klartext
Reinschreiben
Nein wie mach ich das jetzt
Mon KS
Hehehehehe
Ah
Ok ich guck erst mal ob es läuft
Ich guck erst mal ob es läuft Leute
Ich mein das funktioniert jetzt natürlich nicht
Ich will einfach nur mal gucken ob es jetzt
Startet wenigstens
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen
Config File
Ist not a valid host
Der ist wieder
Der wills wieder wissen
Ist doch nicht so einfach
Äh ich glaub man muss
Ah so geht das mit BasicAuth
Ok
Interessant genau das
Genau das brauchen wir
Da geb ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht
Das Passwort ein
Weil ansonsten leake ich das Passwort
Aber ich schreib schon mal alles rein was man braucht
Alps
BasicAuth 0w
Nicht das richtige Passwort
So darf ich jetzt starten
Ab
Ah Gott
Wo ist das Problem
Was
Permission
Please
Das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert
Ok
Ich kopier mir das jetzt einfach von meinem anderen
Von meiner anderen Installation rüber
Da hab ich nämlich schon funktionierendes
Grafana Command
So
Also
User
Ich habs doch hier noch offen oder
So
Äh also hier Grafana
User
Hab ich da drin stehen
Ports
Ports ist egal bei Host Networking
Und Prometheus
Hab ich
Diesen Crap hier drin stehen
Unter Command
Mal gucken was es jetzt macht
Ah Yes
Schon gleich viel besser
Ok also
Gehen wir mal hin
Äh Localhost 3000
Ist Grafana glaub ich
Jawoll
Eine Runde Grafana am Start
Oh das sieht jetzt advancer aus als vorher
Home
Login
Admin ist glaub ich Default
Dont Save
New Password 123456
Excellent
Da kommt man nie drauf
Ok Datasource hinzufügen
Warum sieht denn das hier so kaputt aus
Datasource
Prometheus Localhost
Ja kann sein
Konnte man
Das nicht noch testen
Datasource Working
Jawoll
Save
Sehr gut
Ok
So Chat und jetzt müsst ihr mal weggucken
Jetzt müsst ihr weggucken Chat
Jetzt trage ich nämlich das Passwort
Das Passwort da drin ein
Dürft ihr nicht sehen
Leaked
Es ist nicht schlimm wenn ihr es seht
Ich verwende den Server eh für nix
Aber ich hab keinen Bock dass wieder irgendwelche DDoS Jungs am Start sind
Oder sowas
Also ich werde die Augen zumachen Leute
Sind zu ok nice
Gehasht gehasht ist nackt
Das wäre ja sicher
Ok wir sind wieder am Start
Nice
Ok also wir sind wieder da
Jetzt gucken wir mal ob der
Ob der abfragt
Äh
Wir können uns die Logs angucken
Dann machen wir jetzt das hier
Warte mal ich mach den Kram einmal down noch
Minus F glaub ich fürs löschen oder so
Und jetzt machen wir nochmal ab
Ok
Ähm
Docker compose
Prometheus
Mal gucken ob es funktioniert
Äh Logs
Scheint zu funktionieren
Add your first data source
Select
http slash localhost
90 90
Save jawoll
Back oh ne jetzt haben wir es doppelt drin
Keck wait
Ist on stream chat broken
Ne geht immer noch
Äh den können wir
Den wieder löschen
Wenns schon drin ist
Also jetzt sollten wir hier eigentlich bei explore irgendwie
Kram drinne haben
Wie auch immer wenn der jetzt da ordentlich crawlt
Äh sollte jetzt
Eigentlich Sachen auftauchen dort
Ne weil ich hab das hier drinne
Schaun wir mal
Schaun wir mal ob da jetzt im Grafana was auftaucht
Äh man muss suchen nach
No matrix found
Ich würd jetzt eigentlich erwarten das das funzt
Wir warten jetzt mal ab und machen auf dem Server weiter
Dann können wir nachher noch nice nice
Was hab ich denn hier im Wim auf Leute
Hab ich noch den Wim auf
Kack noob
Ne hab ich nicht
Ist ein anderer Wim
Ok also machen wir mal auf dem Server weiter
Wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben
Jetzt müssen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache kommen
Ich will meinem MQTT Server beibringen
Ich hab ein Zertifikat
Kaddi hat das Zertifikat ausgestellt
Man sieht ja das es funktioniert
Hier gültiges Zertifikat am Start
Alles klar
Ah guck mal er hat
Er hat discovered ok
Jetzt machen wir ein nice dashboard
Grafana Linux Server Dashboard
Da gibts noch so ein Standard
So ein Standard Overview Dashboard
Moment
Das Default Dashboard
Beste
Node Exporter Full
Den da meine ich
Copy ID
Zack
Dashboard
Wo ging das jetzt nochmal
Import
ID Load
Datasource Import
So excellent Leute
Massive Dashboard
Letzten 24 Stunden
So Massive Dashboard
Da geht jetzt den ganzen
Controlling und
Personalabteilungsleuten einer ab
Wenn Dashboards am Start sind
Dashboards ist das aller wichtigste
Egal ob da was geiles drinsteht
Aber Dashboards
So jetzt haben wir schon mal unser nicest Dashboard
Für unseren Server
Für die Stonks Leute
Die sitzen jetzt hier da
Und freuen sich über
Das Dashboard
Das füllt sich jetzt übrigens gleich noch ein bisschen
Mit den Daten vom Server
Und man muss sagen das war echt relativ easy
Die meisten Leute werden Grafana und Prometheus daheim schon haben
Die sowas machen wollen
Man installiert den Node Exporter
Macht den Reverse Proxy davor
Und gut ist
Ich muss jetzt nochmal auf mein Ansible Zeug achten
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas gemacht
Was ich in Ansible noch nachbauen muss
Prometheus Node Exporter
Oh ja na klar
Ok das muss ich mir aufschreiben
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben
Also was brauchen wir noch
Also das Cuddy File muss da rein
Muss rein in Ansible
Der Pricechamp Twitter Bot
Ich weiß nicht ob ich den noch mache
Das Problem beim Pricechamp ist
Das ist eigentlich viel pflegeintensiver als ich gedacht hatte
Ich weiß nicht ob ich das noch
Lange update
Das nervt mich das ich so viel von Hand machen muss
Ich hab eigentlich gedacht das geht einfacher
Muss ich mal gucken
Es gibt noch viele Leute
Deswegen behalte ich es auch erstmal
So nice
Jetzt haben wir Poggers Graph
Nun gucken wir mal
Das wir dem MQTT Server beibringen
Das wir
Zertifikate verwenden wollen
Für die Connections
Standardmäßig
Standardmäßig steht da glaube ich
Nichts drin
Sondern einfach nur dieses Default Zeug
Also sprich der lauscht jetzt
Auf Port
Keymarks
Netstat
Auf Port 1883 lauscht
Der ist in der Firewall gar nicht frei
Wie viele sind auf dem Pricechamp
Um die 300.000 Leute schon diesen Monat
Gar nicht so übel ne
Der Pricechamp wurde gestern auf Reddit empfohlen
Ernsthaft
Reddit
Muss ich gucken
Jeder Pricechamp denn überhaupt
Ja funktioniert
Pricechamp
Die Reddit Suche sackt aber
Es kann durchaus sein das es nicht funktioniert
Das ist
Die Reddit Suche ist kacke
Ah hier hier okay zeig mal
Sonst gibt es doch ne kleine Kaufbranche
Hehehe
Hä
Stand da nicht eben 9 Antworten
Achso hier
Mittlerweile ist Reddit schon ein bisschen fail oder
Guck mal hier
Nice
Da bin ich immer froh wenn ich das lese sowas
Ja New Reddit Layout
Ist echt Paintschamp
So Leute guck mal
Jetzt können wir uns am schönen Dashboard erfreuen
Wie Poggas das aussieht für unseren Server
Und wir kriegen es jetzt automatisch
Nach dem Setup
Okay mal kurz in mich gehen
Wir wollen jetzt die MQTT
Config machen also
Mosquito
Conf D
Touch
Was touchen wir
Wir touchen ein
Touchen ein
Keine Ahnung
SSL Conf
So und da ich habe mir schon angeguckt
Was man da rein schreiben muss
Easy ich habe Copy Paste die jetzt
Also
Listener das ist der Port
Auf dem er
Das ist der Port
Auf dem er später verfügbar sein soll
So
Und dann
Muss man ihm sagen
CA File
Cert File
Da muss ich noch gucken wo die Dinger liegen
Und Key File
Und dann sollte es funktionieren
Hier ist er nochmal
Sirius Max wie hast du das jetzt gefunden
Die Reddit Suche geht bei mir nicht
Oder benutzt du
Oder benutzt du Old Reddit
Old Reddit Suche
Das muss ich jetzt gucken ob Old Reddit funktioniert mit der Suche
Wartet mal
Old Reddit
Ne geht auch nicht
Side Reddit
Was witzig ist ne
Ah nice
Was witzig ist
Reddit Suche suckt einfach so hart
Ja das stimmt
Das stimmt aber ich kann halt nichts machen
Wenn die Seite nicht drin ist
Öff bei Google
So also weiter gehts
Wie bringen wir das dem jetzt bei
Also wo hat Kaddi die Zertifikate abgelegt
Ist jetzt ja die große Frage
Suchen wir mal nach
Ähm
Ich fang einfach mal Google
Kaddi Zert Directory
Location
Where does Kaddi keep Zertifikates
Excellent genau das will ich wissen
The Kaddi Folder
Ja ok das heißt wir suchen nach einem Folder der Punkt Kaddi heißt
Alles klar
Slash Name
Punkt Kaddi
Zahl ich her wo gibts da was
Gar nicht
Wir suchen einfach ohne Punkt
Hätt ich auch escapen müssen
Äh
Da
Da sind die Zertifikate
Na wer wird
Tatsächlich
Das ist das richtige
Na wer hätte da nicht drinnen gesucht
Wer hätte da schon nicht drinnen gesucht
Also
Voll intuitives Verzeichnis
Kommt man doch locker drauf
So
SSL Conf
Welche Dateien brauchen wir da jetzt
Äh CA File bin ich mir
Nur nicht sicher Zert File
Zert File ist das
Da
Und das Key File ist
Das da
So und Zert File
Zert File brauchen wir eigentlich den
Das Let's Encrypt
Kann man auch Zert Pass nehmen
Weil Zert Pass ist einfach
Das ist ETC SSL
Da sind die ganzen
Die ganzen äh CA
Also nicht die Keys
Die gesignten CA Dinger
Ähm wem vertraut wird
Trusted wird
Da ist auch Let's Encrypt dabei
Irgendwo
Mal gucken ob es sowas gibt
Also ich weiß das es beim Kommandozeilen Tool gibts
Es gibt es äh SSL
Äh gibt es CA Pass
Aber ich weiß nicht ob es das in der Server Config gibt
Werden wir jetzt gleich sehen
Restart
Restart Mosquitto
Bam
Die Chain of Trust genau
So
Hat das jetzt funktioniert Status
Tatsächlich hat es funktioniert
Ok also von der Idee her
Haben wir jetzt
Am Start
Einen
Webs
Einen MQTT Server
Mit Zertifikat
Das müssen wir jetzt allerdings mal ausprobieren ob das auch funktioniert
Und da sagen wir hier Mosquito
Keine Ahnung
Ähh
Wir gucken einfach mal ob wir uns lokal dazu subscriben können
Bevor ich den Port aufmach
Sub
Host Local
Port 883
Topic
Alles
Boah jetzt bin ich mir nicht sicher
Und jetzt gibt es glaube ich CA Pass
Und dann ETC
SSL Search
Das wäre ja auch zu einfach wenn das funktioniert hätte
Das wäre ja auch
Easy
Sneaky Boy Dankeschön
Dankeschön für den Sub
So also
ETC SSL Search
Wie heißt denn das richtige Let's Encrypt Zertifikat
Let's Encrypt
Welches ist denn da das richtige
Ach guck mal
Lull
Das erste was du findest ist sogar irgendeine Mosquito Config
Nice also was
DST Root
Alles klar und das ist die Let's Encrypt
CA
Okay
Ich glaub das jetzt einfach mal
Hast du vor den Preis zu open sourcen
Ja vielleicht
Wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe daran zu arbeiten
So starten please
SSL Error
Dann gebe ich das doch mal direkt an
Warum
Warum geht das nicht
Anzeige ist raus was soll das
SSL Error
Habe ich den
Habe ich das Restarted hier schon
SSL Error
Ähh ja
Sehr schön
Ähm
Was habe ich verkehrt gemacht
Okay wir gucken nochmal kurz rein
Wie haben die Dudes hier das gemacht
Der SSL Error
Ist ganz toll
Ja genau so sieht es doch bei mir aus
Aber
Aber ganz genau so sieht es bei mir aus
Ah ich weiß was ich
Falsch mache Leute
Ich weiß was ich falsch mache
Ich muss ja den Domain Namen verwenden
Ich kann ja nicht einfach die IP verwenden denke ich mal
Test SAV Punkt
Ah
Fuck
Hä Moment warum geht das ohne
Warum
Warum geht das ohne
Wartet mal
Und jetzt schicke ich mal eine Message
Und guck ob es funktioniert
Hopp
Ja schön das du einen Weg her gefunden hast
Okay
Ähm
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal Test
Port Topic Topic 0w
Message
Äh größer keck w
Connection was los
Okay excellent excellent
Ah Moment das ist CA Pass
CA Pass ist ja auch falsch
Ich muss ja auch
Ah jetzt funktioniert es
Guck mal Leute kaum macht man es richtig
Kaum macht man es richtig funktioniert es
Das war schon richtig
Guckt so
Offiziell
Es ist offiziell bestätigt
0w ist größer keck w
Ich meine da steht es
Was schwarz auf weiß
Das ist ja einfach so
Mal gucken wie viele Messages
Der Server so ab kann
Ah juckt ihn nicht
Okay es funktioniert
Nice
Wie bring ich dem Ding jetzt noch
Wie bring ich jetzt noch Benutzer
Authentifizierung der ganzen
Message Geschichte bei
Password File
Example
Der Roger
Der Roger ist Authentifiziert
Der Roger kommt weg
Okay Mosquito
Äh
Warte mal das stand doch bei
DigitalOcean im Guide stand das doch irgendwo drin
Hier wir haben jetzt den Guide
Zwar nicht
Http
Wir haben den Guide zwar nicht verfolgt
Hier Mosquito PassWD
Alles klar
Your Username
Alles klar so machen wir das
Your Username 0w
Okay
Password
Bam
Und jetzt sagt man dem hier
Ist das nicht
Ist die Default Config nicht ein bisschen gefährlich
Wenn er standardmäßig
Standardmäßig die
User drinstehen
Ah ne die User stehen ja gar nicht drin standardmäßig
Okay ich hab nichts gesagt
Das ist einfach nur ein Beispiel gewesen
Und jetzt muss man das File
Allow Anonymous False Password
File Mosquito PassWD
Alles klar
Machen wir
Easy
Benutzt der Qt Messenger auch Qt
Paintschamp
So
Allow Anonymous False
Also Leute
Wie man beim Wim nach unten pastet weiß wahrscheinlich jeder
Weil man P drücken muss
Mit P pastet man nach oben
Wim Magic
Restart
So
Auf Restarten
Please
Dankeschön für die Subs
NoLimitXO 10 Monate am Start
Und Dannyboy3000 auch am Start
Nice Dankeschön für die Subs
IQ++++++
Für den Chat hier wieder
Was ist das
Exquisite
Okay Sub
Sollte jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren
Okay User
Fragt er mich dann nach dem Passwort
Kann man Passwort prompten lassen
Oder so
Passwort prompten
Sub prompt Password
Wie ich muss denn
Ernsthaft
Die wollen das ich das da im Klartext reinschreib
Wirklich
Das ist doch für den Arsch wer bedenkt sich sowas aus
Der Promptet nicht
Also Username
Es gibt noch
Minus Minus PW
Könnt ihr euch mal entscheiden wie das nun mittlerweile heißt
Ach das ist das gleiche
Okay das ist richtig
Das ist richtig Oldschool
Ne ich glaub das ist kein Bash Script
Das ist
Irgendeine Java Crap oder so
Keine Ahnung
Ich weiß gar nicht in was das programmiert ist
Okay es gibt witzigerweise
Ich muss das ernsthaft im Klartext angeben
Seid ihr in Ernst
Okay ich glaub einfach das es funktioniert
Leute wir vertrauen einfach mal drauf
Das es funktioniert
Ich will das jetzt nicht im Klartext angeben
Und ähm
Jetzt würde ich sagen machen wir den Port mal auf
Weil ich muss ja von Lokal
Drankommen
Leute ich hab ne Idee
Ich mach ne Environment Variable
Und das übergebe ich dann da
Also Moment
Ihr werdet jetzt ausgeblendet
Wie gesagt es ist nicht wirklich schlimm ich verwende den Server eh für sonst nix
Gleich
So Zack
Da sind wir wieder
Hab ich das Lokal installiert
Okay
Der Port ist noch nicht auf
Alles klar passt ja auch
Waren wir mal den
Port auf
Äh UFW
Woran listen das jetzt nochmal
Okay UFW allow
Und jetzt minus
Dollar MQTT
Pw
Hatte ich eben vergeben
Hä ich hab das doch eben gesetzt
Achso minus Username muss ich noch machen
U Lul W
Connection was refused
Aber warum
No Password specified
What
Ich hab das doch eben
Ich hab doch eben Umgebungsvariable gemacht
Mit dem Kack Passwort alter
Ah ich bin doof Leute ich bin dumm
Ich hab mich verschrieben
Ich hab es
Ah lol jetzt hab ich Passwort geleakt
Passwort liegt lol
Jetzt kann ich es auch eingeben
Ist eh wurscht ich verwende das für sonst nirgends wo was
So
Funktioniert
Excellent
So
Kann ich auch subben
Hehehe Passwort
Moment
Sub
Passwort
Music Salami ICQ
Jetzt funktioniert es Leute
Alles gut
Excellent
Jetzt muss ich das Passwort changen
Wobei ne ich muss das Passwort nicht changen
Weil
Ich mach einfach
Das wieder raus
M
S
Und es kann eh nix großartig passieren
So ähm
Dann deleten wir noch 443
Ups
Warte mal
Man konnte doch auch sagen allow
Man konnte konnte man nicht
Einfach sowas hier sagen delete allow 443
Und delete allow
Ja genau so geht das
Ne HTTPS
Ah ja nice
Guck mal jetzt die Firewall nehm ich wieder dicht
Ja gut ähm
Das Passwort
Ich hab einfach die letzten 3 Emotes
In meinem Dashboard genommen
Die letzten 3 Emotes sind
Musik Salami ICQ
Ich hab irgendwas gebraucht
Was man nicht erraten kann
So auf Instant
Da passiert ja nix großartig
Das ist ein temporärer Server
Mit unsinnigen Dingern
Selbst wenn einer das Passwort jetzt hat
Bringt ihm gar nix im Endeffekt
So
Also
Das funktioniert alles
Was wir jetzt noch
Eine Sache
Die ich jetzt noch nicht kapiert hab
Das ist auch
Das ist alles in Ordnung so wie es ist
Das einzige was wir noch machen müssen ist
Wenn
Das Passwort
Erneuert wird vom Kaddi
Dann muss ich
Den
Den Moskito neu starten
Weil der lädt das ja nicht automatisch neu
Und ich hab gelesen
Das ist ein Reload
Ein Reload tut es nicht fürs Zertifikat
Es muss ein Restart sein
Jetzt macht er eigentlich unser nicest Dashboard
Oh
Unser Dashboard
Exquisite Dashboard
Achso ich hab die Firewall wieder zugemacht
Ja jetzt geht das Dashboard kaputt
So es heißt eigentlich
Für die Sache könnte ich so machen
Ich mach einfach einmal nachts
Ne Neustart über nen Cronjob
Das ist zwar nicht die schöne Variante
Was der Node Exporter
Das ist
Das ist das Standard
Das ist das spezielle Dashboard
Für den Prometheus Node Exporter
Da ist einfach alles was es gibt
Alles was es gibt mit
Mit drinnen
Salami ist so tos
Das es bei FFZ
Und bei der TwitchTV und so gelöscht wurde
Also man könnte doch jetzt im Prinzip
Die ganz easy Variante wäre
Einfach CronDaily Eintrag zu machen
Da sagen wir mal irgendwie
MQTT
Das ganze zu nennen
Bin Bash
Dann einfach das reinschreiben
Das wars
Das ist zwar nicht schön
Da wird einmal nachts die Verbindung gekappt
Aber das ist für meine Presence Detection
Jetzt nicht wirklich relevant
Warum muss ich neu starten
Falls das Zertifikat geupdatet wurde
Also wenn Cudi das Zertifikat updatet
Bekommt der MQTT Server das nicht mit
Man könnte das
Man könnte das sicherlich schöner machen
Oh Leute ich hab ne Idee
Ich weiß wie wir es machen
Wir gucken ob es heute gechanged wurde
Und wenn es heute gechanged wurde
Dann restarten wir Mosquito
Das ist doch schöner
Ok
Also Stat
Stat auf den
Ist eigentlich egal
Auf das Zert
So
Genau
Das ist eigentlich ne gute Idee
Ich baue das in den Cron Shop ein
Wenn es heute gechanged wurde
Das Zertifikat
Dann startet er den
Den Neu
Das ist doch gut
Und es läuft Daily
Also an irgendeinem Tag ist es auf jeden Fall
Da wird es nicht jede Nacht neu gestartet
Das ist ne schönere Variante oder
Viel zu viel Aufwand
Wieso hat es keinen Nutzen
Dann bricht einmal nachts die Verbindung nicht ab
Da kann ich übertragen
Dass ich im Bett liege
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich gescheit
In dem Skript
Test File
File
Modified oder so
Modified
Bash if File
Modified Today
Stack Overflow Driven Programming
Ah Yes
Stack Overflow weiß wieder Bescheid
Das ist immer geil
Warum selbst überlegen
Wenn man einfach Stack Overflow suchen kann
Marvinson schreibt
Mahlzeit
Ich habe mir Dell für eine Ausbildung zum Physi beworben
Da ich aber schon eine Ausbildung zum Mechatroniker habe
Und sehr viel Ahnung von Computern
Allgemein habe
Habe ich die von Dell mir direkt eine festgestellt
Das ist doch nice
Also wenn ich dazu beigetragen habe
Ist das Poggers
Finde ich auch Poggers
Das ist nice
Aber ich muss mal dazu sagen
Ähm
Vielleicht machen die das auch nicht ganz
Aus reiner Nächstenliebe
Und wollen dich für ein Apfel und ein Ei beschäftigen
Also
Was ich immer sagen muss unterm Strich
Einfach immer mal gucken das man sich nicht verarschen lässt
Danke für den Sub
Du kannst auch das Pit fallen
Oh jetzt wird es aber
Jetzt wird es aber advanced
Weiß gar nicht wo das liegt
War
Irgendwas
So ist das gut
Only Modification Time
Innerhalb der letzten
Sind das was Tage
Oder Minuten
Modified Date
Ok
Gucken wir mal ob das stimmt
Ähm
Gehen wir mal da in das
Verzeichnis rein
Und jetzt
Äh
Was
Ähm
Stehe ich das jetzt nicht
Achso älter als
Äh Minus
Ah yes
Also Dateien die quasi
Innerhalb der letzten 120 Minuten
Genau
Der letzten
Keine Ahnung was ist denn ein Tag
Minutes
Alter der Sound wieder
Moment
Day
Aha
1044 Minuten
Exquisite
Fuck
So so brauchen wir das
Zack Zack
Ok das schreiben wir jetzt in den Cron Shop rein
Cron
If
Feind das mit dem Test brauchen wir übrigens gar nicht
Das mit dem Test brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht oder
Der Return Code reicht doch vom Feind
Was hat das Feind für einen Return Code
Wenn es was findet und was hat es
Versus wenn es nichts findet
Den Test braucht man glaube ich gar nicht
Feind
Findet was hat Return Code
Na ok meinetwegen
So und jetzt was woran achso ähm
Und jetzt woran nichts
Findet 0
Ok passt doch
Also If
Erstmal in das Verzeichnis wechseln
Oh Feind
Feind hier das da
Ne ne
Ne ne minus minus 1 4 4 0 war es
So
Find also wenn Feind irgendwas
Findet dann
Starten wir neu
Ansonsten
Machen wir eigentlich
Nix
Ah ne äh nicht dann
So fertig
Das sollte jetzt von der Idee her funktionieren
1 3 3 7
Ja dann da ist das stimmt von Logik
Ja nicht mehr
Lassen wir das mal laufen
Run Parts
Cron
Ich glaube so ging das
Funktioniert Leute funktioniert
Und er startet neu deswegen hängt das jetzt so lang
Ja by the way wer mal
Cron Shops manuell testen will so
Status
Wurde
Gestartet vor 11 Sekunden
Ok Cron Shop passt alles klar
Easy Easy
Ok also
Im Endeffekt was müssen wir jetzt noch in Ansible übertragen
Das Cuddy File
Die Mosquito Config
Und den Cron Shop oder das war es doch
Oder habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen
Ich glaube das war alles
Man kann auch die Systemzeit ändern
Allerdings weiß ich gar nicht wann Daily standardmäßig läuft
Ich glaube um 3 oder so
Sehr schön sehr schön
So und das ergibt ja alles in
UFW einschalten
UFW
SSH erlauben
So
Moment was mache ich denn da
Die Musik ist wieder nice
So
Updaten
Mosquito installieren
Cuddy installieren
Cuddy starten alles klar
Ok
Ok jetzt müssen wir noch das Cuddy File reinschreiben
Ich
Automatisier gerade den Server Aufbau
Hier
Also wir haben es jetzt erst immer hingekriegt dass es an sich
Funktioniert
Also Moment wir brauchen das Cuddy File brauchen wir
Und dann
Testen wir auch mal ob es funktioniert
Klar was wir da gemacht haben
Also das Cuddy File
Ups
Ich habe es geöffnet
Firewall ist zu das kann nicht funktionieren
Also
Ähm wie
Wie
Kriege ich jetzt in das Cuddy File ordentlich
Was rein
Cuddy Setup Reverse Proxy
Also ich muss in das Cuddy File ja dieses Ding hier rein kriegen
Ähm
Pass
Insert After
Ähm Line
Moment kann ich da nicht einfach
Irgendwas
Was ist Line in File
Was habe ich da das letzte mal gemacht
Inside After
Kann ich nicht einfach Config File da rein schreiben
Hardcoded
Ähm Ansible
File
Wie übertrage ich denn den Kram
Hier jetzt
Ja Content
Access Time
Ich will einfach nur File Content
Hinschreiben
Ja denn Template
Template weiß ich aber geht das nicht einfacher
Ich will eigentlich kein extra Template File machen
Oder heißt das nur Template
Multiple
File Line
Block in File was ist das denn
Insert Update
Remove Block of Multiline Text
Genau das will ich haben
Template
Template braucht man glaube ich ein extra File ne
Wobei ist das
Das mit Template ist doch eigentlich fast besser
Das mit dem Template ist doch eigentlich fast
Fast noch
Fast noch besser
Welche Rechte brauchen das Cuddy File
Gut
Ok das ist ja einfach
Dann machen wir das doch mal hier rein
Also Cuddy File brauchen wir
Aber machen wir mit dem Template
Ist glaube ich äh
Sinniger
Also Template
Source
Äh ja
Templates
Bezieht sich das auf das Verzeichnis
Indem ich es ausführe
Oder
Muss ich sowas hier machen
Source
Wobei ich mach einfach sowas hier
Ich hab ja aktuell nur ein
Ich glaub groß schreibt man
Ich hab ja aktuell nur ein Verzeichnis wo das alles drin ist
So
Destination etc Cuddy
Cuddy File
Das ganze gehört Root
Gruppe Root
Und 644 passt
So dann legen wir mal ein File an
So haben wir nämlich den Content
Haben wir schon hier drinnen
Genau das da wollen wir haben
Ich glaub das müsste
Ich glaub das müsste funktionieren
So also das Cuddy File haben wir jetzt drin
Die Mosquito Config brauchen wir
Auf jeden Fall
Die war ähm
ETC
ETC Mosquito
Äh
konf D
SSL
Conf
Das Geile ist wenn man das einmal gemacht hat
Habe ich auf
Upps
Habe ich auf einen Blick
Und ich kanns einfach wieder hinstellen
So. Wir wollen das File anlegen
temperature
calculation
Source, ähm,
nennen wir es einfach mal so.
Root, Root, stimmt das?
Root, Root, alles klar.
Kadi enablen können wir hier nach.
So, also.
etc.conf.de, SSL links,
SSL.conf, die müssen wir anlegen.
SSL.conf
hat er mir doch hier gerade.
Oder auch nicht, habe ich da nicht reingeguckt.
Genau das da.
So.
Und das war's, glaube ich.
Ich sogar schon.
Kommt der ganze Kram?
Achso, der Cron-Shop, der Cron-Shop noch.
Ah.
Mosquito.
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen, außer dem Cron-Shop
jetzt?
Glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
So, Ansible, Cron, wie machen wir mit Ansible den Cron?
Das war doch auch relativ easy, hatte ich doch schon.
Kann man da auch einfach sagen,
Daily? Genau, Special Time, Daily.
Special Time.
Hier haben sie ein Beispiel, genau.
So.
Äh, das Mosquito-Passwort-File.
Ah, genau, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, sehr gut.
Chat, Big Brain, wie immer.
So, Create, so, äh, ähm.
So, der Cron-Shop, den haben wir irgendwo hier drinnen stehen.
Achso.
Äh.
Kann ich inline den Cron-Shop-Skript reinschreiben? Geht das?
Ach hier, Job, guck mal da.
Exquisite.
Jetzt wird's, das machen wir mal so, hier.
Achtung, alles, alles schön inline reinfummeln.
Ah, yes.
Wobei, ne, der fährt, der führt das doch bestimmt standardmäßig Bash-mäßig aus, oder?
CD?
Easy, easy.
Wir machen das jetzt alles, alles one, one line.
Moment, man kann das doch bestimmt multi-line machen, oder?
Man kann das doch bestimmt multi-line.
Moment, wie, wie, wie ging, wie ging multi-line nochmal in, ähm, äh, in, in YAML?
Das war doch so ein komisches Sonderzeichen, irgendwie sowas da?
YAML, multi-line.
War das ein Pipe?
Sowas da, ne?
Juss.
Ah ja, ah ja, Pipe, Pipe, ich will Line-Breaks preserven.
Und okay, wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Pipe, Key, Pipe und dann?
Einfach so dahinter, ne?
Exquisite.
Massive Code, Alter.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt, mal gucken, was da rauskommt jetzt.
So, jetzt haben wir den Cron-Shop.
Muss man das einmal einrücken?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Okay, jetzt haben wir den Cron-Shop zum, zum Neustarten.
Jetzt fehlt uns nur noch das Passwort-File.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch das Passwort-File.
Und das Passwort-File gibt's...
unter ETC-Mosquito...
äh...
PWD.
Pass-WD.
Pfeil.
So.
Das war mal ein Template.
Ich muss, ich muss den Mos, ich muss den Mosquito danach noch neu starten.
So.
Und jetzt kommt das Template, kopieren wir hier gleich mit hin.
Pass-WD.
Das muss man auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen ordentlicher machen.
Nach Conf, Pass-WD.
Äh...
Und jetzt, wie, wie restartet man ein Service?
Service...
Ich kann bestimmt einfach sagen Restart zum Schluss dann.
Service, Restart, Ende.
Special Time hab ich nicht gemacht.
Ah ja, ah ja.
Lull.
Beim Reboot.
Äh...
So, ähm...
Restart.
Okay.
State Restart.
Gut.
Ich würd sagen, jetzt haben wir alles...
Alles drin.
Wir, wir, wir löschen den...
Ich hab nix vergessen, glaube.
Wir löschen den Server mal und gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, den automatisch aufzubauen.
Da bin ich ja mal huge gespannt.
Äh...
Moment.
Ich geh noch mal kurz in mich.
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ja.
Ich...
Ich hab noch was.
Ob ich irgendwas vergessen hab?
Moment, warum ist meine Bash-History so kurz?
Ach, nie.
Isse gar nicht.
Ich hab da.
Ich hab ja das...
Tmaks gehabt dann.
Nää, egal.
Also, wird schon.
Wird schon passen.
So.
Server...
Server, äh...
Neubauen?
Hetzner, komm her.
Recreate.
Rebuild.
Eatbild.
.
Ubuntu 20.4.
Rebuild.
.
Okay.
Mal gucken.
Man kommt jetzt rein.
Ihnen.
Erstmal den Key wieder rausschmeißen.
Ah, ich hab noch was vergessen, Leute.
Ich hab noch was vergessen. Ich muss die Ports
aufmachen. Guck mal, ich muss
die Ports aufmachen. Ich erlaube
HTTP, HTTP-Dings.
Ich muss noch Port 883
erlauben.
So, also von der Idee her, lass mal
überlegen. Gibt das irgendwie Sinn, was wir hier machen?
Wir erlauben SSH, dass wir uns nicht aussperren.
Dann erlauben wir
HTTP, HTTPS,
ähm, MQTT.
Dann sagen wir
Firewall ist aktiv.
Dann machen wir Updates mit Paketen, installieren
Standardsachen, installieren MQTT.
Passt. Ähm, aktivieren
den ganzen Kram. Dann installieren wir
den Webserver. Auch alles klar.
Ähm,
ich glaub, einen Kati-Restart
brauch ich am Ende noch.
Dann installieren wir, genau, hier installieren wir einen Kati.
Dann machen wir das Kati-Firewall.
Dann machen wir das Kati-File hin.
Ne, hier mach ich das. Enable, Restart. Kann ich.
Alles klar. Danach mach ich die
Konflikts für MQTT hin.
Ich enable den Kram.
Äh,
Restart.
Restart ich MQTT und mach am Ende noch
einen Con-Shop hin. Okay.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ich bin ja mal, ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Okay, Server-Login
funktioniert schon wieder. Alles klar.
Da führen wir den Kram mal aus. Jetzt bin ich echt gespannt,
ob das klappt.
Äh,
Ansible.
Bam. Oh, RIP.
Okay, das geht mit der Syntax schon mal nicht.
Ähm,
nein. Das heißt, ich brauch für jede
Firewall-Regel was Eigenes.
Kann so Firewall-Regel nicht in einem
machen. Okay.
Ansible, UFW, UFW.
Bin doch bestimmt nicht der Einzige,
der das Problem hat.
Loop. Oh, jetzt wird's advanced, Leute.
What the fuck?
Ah.
Oh. Big brain time,
Alter. Okay, big brain time.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Und was jetzt? Item?
So? Ja, das ist aber
die Loop wird für alles funktionieren, denke ich mal.
Okay.
Komm, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Das funktioniert.
Ja, das ist okay.
Aber es hat funktioniert, guck mal.
Guck mal, der hat eine, der hat eine Schleife
gemacht. Okay, wir sollen
quoten, sagt er.
Dann quote ich die anderen
Dinger auch, einfach aus Prinzip.
Changed. Okay. Jetzt macht er
Update, Upgrade. Das dauert jetzt
eine halbe Minute.
So, in der Zwischenzeit, ich guck mal kurz ein paar Questions,
die ich übersehen hab. Ups, ich kann
das eigentlich von hier machen.
So, äh, äh.
Wo ist das?
Pepega-Board? Da ist das Pepega-Board.
Also. Zeig mal hier, was
hab ich übersehen? Ubuntu-Version.
Ah, also nix.
Oh, oh, das geht gar nicht weiter.
Aber das hatten wir doch schon.
Machst du noch mal ne Room-Tour?
Ja, wenn ich die Möglichkeit hab, mein
Heimatomatisierungszeug zu zeigen, ohne dass
ich so viel leake. Und wenn ich aufgeräumt
hab, dann mach ich ne Room-Tour.
Äh, das hab ich noch nicht gelesen, aber
bin ich mal gespannt. Hatten wir.
Äh, ja.
Für Presence-Detection.
Ja, coole Idee.
Das hatten wir schon, das hatten wir schon.
Das hatten wir auch schon.
Hatten wir alles schon.
Ne, suchen wir, suchen wir
glaube grad keine. Und auch
keinen.
Ja gut. ITIL-Geschichten ist immer so
ein Ding. Da stehen sie auch alle. Alle stehen
drauf, das Wort ITIL zu sagen, aber
wirklich sinnvoll was machen. Haben sie dann, hat dann keiner
Bock drauf. Guck mal hier, jetzt scheint
alles zu funktionieren. Bin ich aber echt gespannt, ob es
danach tut.
Äh, ja. Die war günstig
und die passt für meine Heimatomatisierung-Sachen.
Wie gesagt, Pork-Bahn, aber das
sackt eigentlich. Wie gesagt,
bei meinem Domain-Registranten
hab ich's, oh, oh, oh Mist.
Warum?
Ich hab's geschafft, bei meinem Domain-Registrar
gebannt zu werden.
System-CTL-Status.
Was hat der?
Wie, warum nicht?
Warum?
Hab ich das vorher nicht enabled oder was?
Äh, hä?
Was hat der für Probleme?
Vielleicht sind die Zertifikate
noch nicht da.
Erstmal kurz gucken, dass,
ob die UFW-Regeln stimmen.
Ja, geht. Test-SAV.
Okay, der
Kadi geht auch nicht.
Okay, da ist irgendwas schiefgelaufen.
Ha, ha, da ist irgendwas schiefgelaufen.
Okay, ähm.
Kadi install, install Kadi.
Kadi-File, enable, start Kadi.
Ah. Okay, der Kadi läuft.
Kadi läuft, alles gut.
Status, Status.
Äh, äh.
Ist auch alles da. ETC.
ETC.
Kadi.
Kadi-File.
Auch alles da.
Woran hängt's jetzt genau?
Woran, woran hängt's jetzt genau?
Was hat der für Schmerz?
Ist der Node-Exporter nicht drauf?
Doch.
Nee, UFW ist offen.
80, 443.
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Äh.
Moment, hab ich den Restyle
an der falschen Stelle?
Hab ich den Restyle an der falschen Stelle?
Enable and start.
Ich glaube, ich muss Restart machen.
Ähm.
Ich glaube, ich muss einen Restart machen,
weil Kadi schon läuft.
Kadi läuft nach dem Installen schon.
Deswegen funktioniert das nicht.
Ich muss den,
ich muss den enablen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, wo sind wir?
Hier.
Kann ich hier,
kann ich hier sagen,
State, Restart, geht das?
Restarted?
Das müsste doch,
das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
By the way, warum,
warum ist das Service
und bei dem anderen ist es System D?
Ich glaube, jetzt bin ich,
ich glaube, jetzt bin ich
grad lost.
Ansippel System D.
Restart.
Ich glaube, ich muss
hier auch System D nehmen.
Wenn man zu viel Copy-Pasted.
So, Restart, Restart.
Okay, das ergibt jetzt Sinn.
Okay, ich führe es nochmal aus.
Jetzt macht er den ganzen Kram nochmal,
aber es geht jetzt schneller,
weil das ist ja schon alles durch.
Aber ich bin begeistert mit der Schleife,
das ist viel cooler als in Puppet gelöst.
Puppet sagt, was Schleifen angeht.
Das hat er ja schon alles gemacht.
Hat er auch schon gemacht,
hat er auch schon gemacht,
hat er auch schon gemacht.
Jetzt, Pause-Jump.
Ja?
Okay, er restartet, er restartet.
Er ist jetzt schon mal weitergekommen als vorher.
Was?
Oh, mein Grunt-Shop ist kaputt.
Alles andere funktioniert angeblich.
Ja, ja, funktioniert.
Wie sieht es mit dem Pup aus?
Äh, oder Pup.
Okay, Mosquito funktioniert auch.
Ähm, Start at Task,
das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Was für Schmerzen hat er mit meinem Grunt-Shop?
Start at Task.
Ah, das ist gut.
Das ist perfekt, das brauche ich jetzt.
Äh, Start at Task.
Task, und zwar, ich will starten
ab
dem da.
Okay, was hat er für Schmerzen, was?
Bad Minute Errors in Cron-File.
Ich habe doch gesagt, Daily.
Cron Daily Ansible.
Daily.
Special, Special Time.
Ja, das habe ich doch so drinne.
Was?
An was stört er sich jetzt?
Das ist doch genau, wie es im Beispiel ist.
Oder stört er sich an die Multiline?
Lul weh.
Ah, der stört...
Okay, der stört sich an meinem...
Hm.
By the way, in welcher...
Ah, ja.
Okay, der stört sich an meinem...
an meinem Multiline-Skript.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Was soll das denn?
Anzeige ist raus.
Vielleicht daran, dass da Bash-Shots sind.
Kann man das?
Ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht Multiline machen an der Stelle.
Ich glaube, das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt,
dass man das Multiline macht.
Ich glaube, das geht überhaupt nicht.
Okay, Moment.
Wir machen jetzt Exquisite...
Exquisite One-Line
draus.
If...
Then...
Ich glaube, es muss man...
Ah, jetzt wird immer schöner.
Wird immer schöner.
Äh...
Immer schöner.
schöner und jetzt jetzt funktioniert es guckt jetzt tut von tab genau also hier
geht kein multi line trainer das muss alles in einer zeile sein so wie es
aussieht soll mal gucken ob sich das ganze jetzt auch ausführen lässt was
ich hier gebaut habe moment wie mache ich das irgendwie mache ich das wollen
dann muss ich hier und wie geht das sind best if online habe ich so ich habe das
habe ich doch richtig gemacht moment so rum ist ja auch verkehrt was
ich hier gemacht habe
so so ist richtig von so ergibt es jetzt sind was hier gebaut habe jetzt
funktioniert excellent ok hetzer server wird noch mal platt gemacht und noch
mal aufgebaut excellent excellent ausloggen und jetzt läuft es durch
easy easy win ich habe nur noch eine bedenken warum es nicht funktionieren
könnte und zwar dass die zeit hier dazwischen zu kurz ist guck mal ich mache
hier das ganze jetzt und dann kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann kann
ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann
kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann
kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann kann ich das ganze hier ausführen
und das kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und dann kann ich das ganze hier ausführen
und das kann ich das ganze hier ausführen und jetzt kann ich tatsächlich
auch wenn manaster map an khi cai t Ti пой
kann ich tatsächlich auch wenn man непar genommen habe weil ich denours
die ungehörigen manALI Morgen denomen mit geheimnis und ich kann das hier
nichts sagen means if profile und ganz고
Wir haben ja nicht nur Ansible programmiert, wir haben ja die ganze MQTT-Geschichte ausprobiert.
Pause für
Seconds, geht bestimmt auch, oder?
Seconds, ja.
Seconds für, weiß ich nicht, 30.
Wait for certs.
So.
Was ist eigentlich das für eine MonkaS-Musik?
Oh, ist besser.
Gut.
Okay, ist das Server rebuildet?
Okay, Server ist rebuildet.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay, dann hauen wir mal drauf jetzt.
30 Sekunden warten auf Zertifikat.
Okay.
Plus RNG. Ach ne, gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Bam.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller, darauf zu warten, dass die Zertifikat-Dateien alle da sind?
Kann das, kann das iNotify oder so warten?
Wait for file.
Ah.
Oh, das ist nice.
Okay, file.
To wait for regex match a string to be present in a file.
Wait for a file.
Oh, das ist cool.
Ja, das ist nice.
Das brauche ich.
Das ist viel besser, viel, viel besser.
Wait for.
Das, genau, wait for.
Und dann gebe ich das Zertifikat, den Zertifikats-Fart an.
So ist, so ist das top.
Okay, Ansible.
Aber jetzt breche ich nicht ab.
Zwischendurch.
Ich kann das übrigens nicht mehr so oft machen.
Ich hätte Let's Encrypt endlich auf die Staging-Server stellen sollen.
Weil sonst laufe ich jedenfalls ins Rate-Limit.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Zertifikate man am Tag für eine Subdomain machen kann.
Irgendwie 20 oder so.
Dann sagt Let's Encrypt, nee, nee, jetzt mach erstmal, mach erstmal langsam.
Nee, das geht, es gibt auch globale Limits.
Also man kann es bei Let's Encrypt gar nicht so sehr übertreiben.
Okay, wait.
Jetzt, jetzt macht der CagWait für das Zertifikat.
Schauen wir mal, ob das lang genug wartet.
Äh, wo, wo, wo, wo war das nochmal?
User, Share, Cuddy.
Cuddy, nee, ähm.
Bar, Lib, Cuddy.
Local.
Share, Search.
Okay, es ist alles da.
Alter, MonkaS-Musik.
Jawoll, viel besser.
Okay, okay, ey Leute, es scheint alles zu funktionieren.
Excellent.
Fehlerfrei durchgelaufen.
Äh, Test, SAV.
Metrics sind da.
Jawoll, der Node-Export ist am Start.
Zertifikat ist gültig.
Äh, und MQTT.
Published auch.
Nice, easy, Server aufgebaut.
Fertig, funzt.
So, der nächste Schritt ist jetzt erstmal zu gucken, dass man es etwas, äh, schöner vielleicht noch macht.
Aber das schauen wir mal, Poggers.
Das ist schon mal nice.
Alles funktioniert.
So, hübsch, hübsch ist das Ganze schon mal prinzipiell gar nicht, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Aber es funktioniert.
Ja, übrigens habe ich euch, ja, habe ich schon.
Muss ich gerade nochmal.
Ich habe es ja auch mal bei meinem Domain-Registrar voll übertrieben, ne.
Also, ich bin bei einem ultra low budget Domain-Registrar.
Bei denen hier habe ich meine Domains registriert.
Die sind billig, aber sonst, aber sonst, äh, eigentlich nichts.
So, und das Problem ist, die haben keine DNS-Anbieter.
Die haben keine DNS-API.
Also sprich, wenn man über, wenn man, äh, seine, sein, wenn man Let's Encrypt DNS-Zertifizierung machen, äh, DNS-Challenge machen will,
dann muss man über die DNS-API geheime Secrets dahinter überlegen, hinterlegen, dass es funktioniert.
So, und ich habe mir gedacht, okay, wenn mein Anbieter keine API hat, dann scripte ich das einfach mit einem Headless Chrome.
Und ich habe es im Headless Chrome gescriptet und hatte da einen Fehler drin.
Und dann habe ich irgendwie 500 Mal mich versucht einzuloggen und dann haben sie mich gesperrt.
Aber es kam noch besser.
Danach habe ich den Support angeschrieben und habe gesagt, ah, Leute, tut mir leid, äh, habt ihr vielleicht eine API?
Und dann haben sie geschrieben, nein, wir haben keine API und wir mögen nicht, dass unser Webinterface gecrawled wird.
Habe gesagt, ja, ja, okay, okay, ich mache es nie wieder.
Ähm, entsperrt mich mal.
Haben sie mich entsperrt.
Und dann wollte ich das, das Scrawler-Skript anpassen.
Also dieses Headless Chrome-Skript anpassen für was anderes.
Und habe, habe zwei Tage später oder einen Tag später gesagt, ja, ja, okay, okay, ich mache es nie wieder.
Entsperrt mich mal.
Und dann habe ich zwei Tage später oder einen Tag später vergessen, die Domain zu ändern.
Und habe es ausgeführt, 500 Mal wieder versucht einzuloggen und wieder gebannt.
Nochmal Support angeschrieben.
Support nochmal doof geguckt, hat mich nochmal entbannt.
Krelax15wohler, danke schön für die Prime-Subscription.
Aber ich bin begeistert.
Das ist, das ist nice.
Jetzt weiß ich, guck mal, aber das hat, es hat einen riesen Vorteil.
Es ist zwar kein schönes Ansible hier, aber ich weiß alles, was auf dem Server drauf ist.
Und ich weiß auch genau, wenn er mal nicht geht.
Nach was ich gucken muss.
So, jetzt mal eine Frage an die Ansible-Profis.
Wie, wie würde man das jetzt schöner machen?
Also wie würde man das jetzt zum Beispiel mit den ganzen, also mit den Templates machen?
Da würde man wahrscheinlich einen Template-Ordner machen.
Oder würde man einen Role-Ordner erstellen?
Role, äh, Ansible Role.
Wo man quasi sagt, genau, Roles.
Und dann, äh, Roles MQTT-Server oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, aber ich will, ich hab ja keine, ich hab ja keine Rollen.
Ich hab im Endeffekt einfach einen kompletten, eine komplette Server-Config.
Fertig.
Macht es Sinn?
Macht es Sinn, Playbooks nach Server zu ordnen?
Ja, aber wie, wie soll ich das hier gescheit ver, verrollifizieren?
Erstmal eine UFW machen, dann Package-Installation machen.
Das hier ist halt das komplette Setup für einen Server.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sonderlich schön ver, ver, verrollen kann.
Willst mich rollen, alter.
Also macht's, macht's vielleicht Sinn, Oliver?
Sowas hab ich mir auch gedacht, dass man hier sowas macht wie Templates.
Und dann für den Host-Name.
Also irgendwie sagt keiner, Templates, ähm, dann, äh, äh, Test-SRV.
Und jetzt diese...
SSL-Conf und, äh, Pass-WD und das Cuddy-File.
Dass man das jetzt nach Templates verschiebt.
Ich mein, das ist schon mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen ordentlicher.
Ups.
Das sind Templates.
Also, ich benutze zumindest Templates.
Ohne da was einzusetzen.
Was aber eigentlich auch schon...
Ja, das könnte man natürlich auch noch schöner machen.
Was mir auch überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Ist das hier.
Guckt euch mal den Cron-Job an, alter.
Das ist auch nicht gut.
Also, Azure ist so ein Ding für sich.
Ich kenn Azure über zwei Sachen.
Einmal mit Terraform.
Das ist ja auch quasi...
Aber so ähnlich.
Von der Config her.
Bloß ist halt, sagen wir mal so.
Ansible ist eher so das Tool, wo man sagt, wie genau ein Server konfiguriert soll.
Terraform ist eher für die Infrastruktur.
Oder eben halt dieses, das, das, das.
Wie heißt dieses?
Azure CLI.
Für Bash.
Auf der Microsoft-Schulung wollten sie uns unbedingt überreden dazu, dass man das in PowerShell macht.
Ich wollte net.
Sprich, ich will das in Bash machen.
Ich mach das später auch in Bash.
Oder in Lilux Shell.
In irgendeiner ordentlichen Lilux Shell.
Ich will das nicht unter PowerShell machen.
Geht mal fort PowerShell.
Kannst du nicht ein Shell-Skript auf den Server schreiben und das im Cron-Job ausführen?
Ja, wo...
Leute, ich frage mich ernsthaft.
Was ist der Sinn von diesem...
Jetzt mal wirklich.
Was ist der Sinn von diesem Cron-Modul?
Weil ich könnte doch einfach hierher gehen, eine Datei anlegen.
Sagen wir mal irgendwie MQTT.
Cron oder so.
Ja.
Dann machen wir den Kram rein.
Bin.
Bash.
Dann machen wir hier den Kram mal mit ordentlich Zeilumbruch wieder rein.
So.
Und jetzt, anstatt den Cron-Job, kopiere ich einfach, kopiere ich einfach die Datei dahin.
Das ist doch eigentlich viel sinnvoller.
Nach ETC.
Cron Daily.
MQTT.
Cron.
So.
Dann sage ich Mode 7.00.
Und gut ist.
Also wenn ich es einfach nur Daily auswähle, dann ist es gut.
Also wenn ich es einfach nur Daily ausführen will, ist es doch wahrscheinlich sogar noch
die einfache Variante.
Hey 777 muss das nicht sein.
Cron muss eigentlich nur root ausführbare sein.
Oder?
Achja.
Source.
Genau.
Source ist nicht path-VD, sondern Source ist in dem Fall ja Template.
Muss man das dann auch so angeben?
Template.
Testsav.
Kammern tempt.
Hey Leute.
Man kann das doch.
irgendwelche variablen reinschreiben oder host host gibt es doch garantiert als variablen
irgend sowas wie current host oder sowas test sav mqt.com ja ich muss mir das mal in ruhe angucken
wie man das schön schön modularer macht ja ich habe ja mittlerweile ganz gut überblick was
eingebaut ist aber so die praktische anwendung fehlt man noch ein bisschen
habe ich templates genau templates excelent dann hier auch noch hin überall überall muss
das davor aber schön ist es nett ja schrott die linchen wie wir zu stellen jetzt machen
also würdest du das so hinschreiben oder über das ncp
das mit dateien wieder schwer loswerden ist in puppet übrigens auch so das problem bei diesen
ganzen config management ist was alle gemein haben die können nur das verwalten was definiert ist
also wenn man zum beispiel das hat bei uns auch schon mal ordentlich probleme gemacht dabei bei
bei zertifikaten glaube ich war das auch und zwar bei puppet ist es auch so wenn du dem sagst legt
eine datei hier hin und du löscht das dann aus der config dann bleibt die datei für immer auf dem server
weil es ist ja aus der config raus die fasst das nicht mehr an eigentlich müsste man für jede
datei die man hinzufügt später noch mal noch einen eintrag machen wo man sie auf löschen
setzt das ist ein bisschen problematisch bei diesem ganzen config management deswegen finde
ich den den cloud ansatz systeme einfach zu professionieren und gut ist und wenn man sie
ändern will quasi neu zu erstellen besser dann ist nämlich alles weg du musst übrigens nicht
template host file schreiben was ach so echt jetzt es reicht wenn ich so schreibe reicht das dann
wirklich also der guckt dann selbst nach templates und name von dem ding sollte mal ausprobieren ist
das ding wieder da ich hab's wieder resetet so also was kann man was könnte man jetzt hier noch
mal so auf die schnelle auf die schnelle bisschen schöner machen also so die ufw geschichten die ufw
geschichten machen wir alles in 1 wo wir gerade dabei sind kann das ssh ufw allow mqtt versteht
er versteht er nicht okay muss man so machen oder kann man das schon mal raus schmeißen so ufw allow
http https ssh qtt schon mal ein bisschen kürzer da haben wir die haben wir die schleife drum herum
kann man das da noch mit rein schreiben hat jemand im plan kann man das noch mit rein schreiben hier
naiv policy die neue lň also alles in einem was anstatt loop wäre und with items ist immer man
lernt allen tis aber wo ist der unterschied macht es sind so ein rein syntaktische dinge oder so ja
ich kann mich aussperren wenn das wenn das stürmer ist das geht hier also ich kann mich aussperren wenn
das wenn das sich aufhört um smiths aufzunehmen geht das kann ich auch die gang auch einer frau habe ich
Fehlschlägt, ne
Beziehungsweise, wenn er das zuerst macht
Wenn er das zuerst macht, dann kann er dann
Den da nicht mehr mit ausführen
Das ist, ja, das glaub ich echt keine gute Idee
Glaub so ist, glaub so ist sinnvoller
Aber
Aber das kann man zusammenfassen
Geh ich mal von aus
So
Den Installer können wir auch zusammenfassen
Was Loop hat with Items
Abgelöst
Okay, also was ist jetzt der neueste Shit
Loop oder with Items
Was nimmt man an der Stelle
Bäh
Ne, dann will ich lieber Loop haben
Irgendwelche Keys
Will ich da nicht dazu hinschreiben
So, jetzt haben wir das ein bisschen abgekürzt
Hier, das ist alles in einem
Das machen wir später
Erst mal den ganzen Kaddi Kram installieren
Und das können wir
Das können wir auch zusammenfassen
Guck mal, hier sag ich Restarted
Und hier kann ich sagen Enable
Einfach auch Yes
So
Guck mal, jetzt hat es schon ein bisschen aufgeräumt
So, einmal lass ich es noch laufen
Und guck ob es noch funktioniert
Oder war es das für heute
Was, wow
Hahaha, okay
Ja, jetzt schon mal wieder verkackt
Install Packages
Was hat das für ein Problem
Achso, Install
Moment, Install und Upgrade
Geht nicht in einem
Sehe ich das richtig, ja
Okay
So, jetzt kurz mal zurück kopieren
Wo hatte ich denn das
Okay, das muss man zuerst machen
Update, Upgrade
Da kann ich das hier aber rauslassen
Oh
Ja, jetzt funzt es auch
Also, was war hier mit
Englisch, morgen Englisch Klausur mit dem
Thema Artificial Intelligence
Oh
Ähm
Gibt es ja immer wieder Diskussionen und Dystopien
Über die Zukunft
Was denkst du, wird Künstliche Intelligenz in vielen Jahren
Schlauer als der Mensch sein
Und viele Aufgaben übernehmen
Also ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwelche Terminator-Geschichten
Dabei rumkommen
Viele Aufgaben auf jeden Fall
Ob wir im Bereich
Roboter oder so irgendwie Fortschritte
Machen, dass dann quasi in
Altenpflegeheimen unsere Roboter am Start sind
Mal gucken, ja
Das wäre auf jeden Fall Anwendungsgebiet
Die Japaner sind ja schon dabei
Kennt noch jemand diese
Japanische Altersheim-Robbe
Diese das weiße Fell-Ding
Was sie versucht haben in Altersheimen
Einzusetzen, also sowas könnte ich mir vorstellen
Aber wo es auf jeden Fall
Denke ich
Massiv
Gas geben wird das Ganze
Wenn wir es irgendwie auf die Reihe kriegen
Dass die Dinger sich selbst optimieren können
Ich weiß, das geht jetzt so ein bisschen
Geht jetzt so ein bisschen in Richtung Terminator
Aber wenn wir es schaffen, dass Programme
Andere Abläufe
Optimieren können
So ein bisschen wie das
So ein bisschen in die Richtung
Wie das diese diese
Diese
AI learns
To play Mario Sachen
Machen, weil wenn man es mal genau nimmt
Das ist ja eigentlich
Eine AI, die andere Software
Bedienung von anderer Software
Optimiert, ja, Mario läuft auf
Imulator und die AI bedient
Quasi diesen Emulator
Ich glaube, da werden wir
werden wir auf jeden Fall massig Fortschritte machen
und es wird auch richtig viel bringen.
Und das wird die Sache dann auch
extrem beschleunigen,
wenn die Dinger sich auf diese Art
und Weise verbessern können.
Ich glaube aber,
dass es im Endeffekt für uns eigentlich nur gut sein kann.
Und das erste, was es eh geben wird,
sind irgendwelche
Roboter-Weihfuß oder so.
Man darf die Weebs
nicht unterschätzen.
Sind überall.
Ah, ich hab's wieder
verkackt.
Das stimmt nicht, der Chat hat mich gebatet.
Der Chat hat mich gebatet.
Der Chat hat gesagt, er findet die Datei automatisch.
Und er findet die Datei nicht
automatisch.
Also, ich muss
doch Templates schreiben.
Templates.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ah ne, ich hätte
ab Task starten sollen.
Das muss er das nicht nochmal
machen.
Wobei, passiert ja eh nix.
Ist ja schon alles durch.
Ja, das halten Sieg kenne ich.
Die, die sich dann oben auf die Wand gestellt haben oder so, ne?
Das geht jetzt übrigens gleich wieder kaputt.
Ich sag's nur. Aber es sollte einen Schritt später
kaputt gehen, wenn ich's richtig erkannt hab.
Ja. Ja. Nice.
Nice.
Also, das muss tatsächlich
überall vor die
Templates davor.
Natürlich ein bisschen doof.
Ey, ich hab gesagt,
ich hab gesagt, du sollst
aborten, Alter.
Mach mal.
Jetzt hängt er.
Grip.
Okay, aber das Ansible-Zeug funktioniert.
Ich find das echt nice. Ich muss mich da noch
ein bisschen mehr mit beschäftigen, wie man das schöner,
schöner, modularer machen kann.
Weil zum Beispiel, das da
will ich ja
auf jedem Server machen.
Also, nicht das da, nur SSH.
Das will ich auf jedem Server machen.
Das da will ich auch auf jedem Debian.
Server machen, wenn's neu ist.
Das da auch.
Das da auch, bis halt auf das letzte.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Also, das kann man
bestimmt richtig, richtig cool machen.
Nee, das ist vorbei hier.
Das ist abgekackt, Leute.
So, ich löscht
den Hetzner-Server mal.
By the way, soll ich euch mal zeigen, was mich
der Preis-Champ gekostet hat?
In diesem Monat.
Aber da ist die ganze Entwicklung
drin und zig Rechner, die ich mir dazwischen drin
angelegt hab.
Usage.
Moment.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich hier irgendeinen Screenshot
übertragen kann.
Ja. 100 Euro.
Nee, ich hab noch kein Flex-Tape.
Aber da waren die ganzen
Test-Server und so dabei.
Normalerweise kostet's nur 35 Euro
oder so, die ganzen Kisten zusammen.
Wechsel zu
Digital Ocean. Nee, warum?
Da ist es noch teurer.
Bei dem,
Digital Ocean hätte ich dafür 400 Euro oder so
bezahlt.
Keck, wait.
Muss grad mal den ganzen Crap wieder löschen.
So.
Muss grad mal die ganzen Server
wieder löschen, die ich nicht benutze.
Bevor ich's vergesse.
Genau, hier. Sehr nice.
So, sehr schön.
Genau, ich wechsle in die Magenta-Cloud.
Ja, passt doch eigentlich.
War ja noch relativ
Templates.
Hatte ich doch in dem Ordner, wo ich ausgeführt hab.
Aber danach,
dann haltet ihr nicht den Server-Namen,
den ihr sucht.
Aha.
Die rufen an!
Okay, die sind hartnäckig.
Ey, okay, das ist voll, das ist komplett hängen geblieben.
Aber ich hab den Server eh gelöscht jetzt.
Alles klar, heute haben wir richtig was gelernt.
Exzellent, ich muss mal rebooten, dass ich ein ordentliches
neues Hintergrundbild bekomme.
Nämlich das allerwichtigste heute.
Dass ich noch ein ordentliches Hintergrundbild krieg.
Über Bing Image of the Day,
der einzige Service, für den ich Bing verwende.
Der einzige Service, für den ich Bing verwende.
Für mein Hintergrundbild.
Es hat einer gefragt, was das für ein Niedlungs- ist.
Das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM.
Und FPS-Counter, das allerwichtigste,
was man in der VM braucht.
Okay.
Besseres Hintergrundbild als das letzte.
Excellent.
So, nochmal kurz Updates machen.
Jawoll.
Leute, ich hab den Postman installiert.
Ich hab nicht Postwoman installiert.
Die es ja auch gibt.
Weil Postman
ist das Patriarchat
in Paketvariante.
Das darf nicht sein, dass
es nur Postman gibt.
Also jetzt kein Witz. Es gibt ernsthaft.
Es gibt ein Paket, was Postwoman heißt.
Weil man
Konkurrenz zu Postman schaffen wollte.
Aber jeder
wie er will.
Ey, wenns das bessere Programm ist,
dann hats sogar was gebracht.
Wobei man ja ganz korrekter
Weise. Da sieht man mal, was das für was das ist.
es für witzige ausmaße mittlerweile annimmt man darf ja eigentlich gar nicht post woman sagen
sondern muss post ich habe vergessen wie muss man sagen post woman muss man sagen woman weil
woman geht ja nicht es darf ja nicht sein dass man woman mit man drin ausspricht
es ist genau das ist geil die also die welt hat heute echt schon ein bisschen dachschaden
ich kenne ernsthaft ich will nicht ausschließen dass welche gibt aber ich kenne niemand weiblich
ist der boxen genannt werden will wobei im moment
ich bin informatiker keller kind ich kenne keine frauen also ist das nicht
repräsentativ der womps in gewalt wird ja gut latin x die machen sich ja selbst drüber lustig
das ist ja egal die amis die amis sind der meinung quasi latino latina geht nicht und
sagen latins und die latinus und latiner
Tinas selber sagen, fuck off und wollen das überhaupt nicht.
Die Welt ist mittlerweile teilweise echt schon verrückt, was das angeht.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich verfolge das teilweise recht amüsiert.
Manchmal schlagen sie ein bisschen über die Stränge allesamt.
Wobei die Gegenseite auch geil ist.
Die übertreibt es dann erst recht.
Und dazwischen, irgendwo dazwischen, gibt es dann noch 4chan, die dafür sorgen, dass OKhand und Pepe auf einmal rassistisch sind und Hate Speech.
Wobei ich mir sicher bin, die wünschen sich heute wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil, dass dieser Trollversuch nicht so gut geklappt hätte.
Man muss sich mal überlegen, ja.
4chan hat so lange rumgetrollt, bis es irgendwann Mainstream-Medien aufgegriffen haben.
Dass Pepe und OKhand White Power ist und Pepe ist auch irgendwas Rassistisches.
Also sprich, die haben so lange rumgetrollt, bis das Mainstream-Medien aufgegriffen haben, haben darüber berichtet.
Und mittlerweile ist es so schlimm, dass echte Nazi-Gruppierungen bei den Amis OKhand als Erkennungssymbol verwenden.
Also das ist quasi vom Troll zur Realität geworden, weil die Leute so dumm sind, Alter.
Das tut weh teilweise.
Das tut weh teilweise, einfach nur.
Die sind so hängen geblieben alle.
Und ich glaube, dass da sogar, ausnahmsweise, sich sogar mal 4chan wünscht, es hätte nicht so gut funktioniert, ihr Trollversuch.
Oh man, da war es echt...
Ich bin der Meinung, es sollten alle mal dem Dalai Lama auf Twitter folgen.
Ich hab's überhaupt nicht mit irgendwelchen religiösen Sachen, aber der erzählt viel sinnvolle Sachen.
Unabhängig davon.
Ob man jetzt irgendwie da Buddhismussachen da anhängt oder nicht.
Aber die Aussagen, die der von sich gibt, der ist halt erleuchtet.
Ja, der weiß Bescheid.
Die sind wirklich Big Brain zum größten Teil.
Da können sich alle mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden.
Da wäre die Welt besser.
Jeden Fall.
Da würde jeder auf den anderen ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen.
Da wäre der Sache schon geholfen, ja.
MrLordChrist, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt noch eine Runde Java-Hate-Speech.
Streamst du jetzt täglich?
Ich habe relativ oft gestreamt.
Letzten Monat fast, fast täglich.
Alle 1-2 Tage.
Aber diesen Monat ist es ein bisschen weniger geworden wieder.
Weil ich ein paar andere Projekte bei mir habe.
Unter anderem hier den Serverraum-Umbau.
Aber...
Ich gucke mal.
Common Sense, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Kann ich mir aber gut vorstellen.
Ja, manchmal gehen so Versuche nach hinten los.
Ja, was macht eigentlich der Frasier?
Ist der Frasier noch am Start?
Der ist vorher off gegangen und hat gesagt,
ich komme heute nicht mehr on.
Aber wir kennen ihn alle.
Wenn der das sagt, muss das nicht unbedingt so sein.
Nee, der Frasier ist nicht mehr on.
Der Helter Steine ist on.
Auch Frankfurter.
Den habe ich mal gesehen.
Am Südbahnhof.
In Richtung Südbahnhof.
Ich habe aber nichts gesagt.
Und jetzt nicht hier irgendwie...
Lass mal YouTube-Video zusammen machen.
Null.
Oder irgendwas kleiner.
Aber ich dachte mir nur, als ich vorbei war,
den kennst du doch.
Den hast du doch irgendwo mal gesehen schon.
Wieso Java-Hate?
Immer.
Einfach weil...
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich gerne flame.
Java und C++.
Und Java...
Das ist eigentlich nur aus Spaß an der Freude.
Java ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber C++ flame ich gerne.
Und C++ ist auch noch schlecht.
Und hat jeden Flame verdient.
Alter, die Musik.
Was jetzt? Hilfe.
Lass mal Klemmbausteine spielen.
Ach, stimmt.
Stimmt.
Lego darf man ja nicht mehr.
Ja, ja.
Sonst ist Lego-Abmahnung gleich raus.
Ja.
Allein schon die Aussprache geht nicht.
Du meinst C++?
C++ ist...
Das ist mittlerweile so abgegeben.
Das ist noch nicht mal die Standard-Leute,
also die Leute, die in diesem Standard-Gremium sitzen,
noch was Einheitliches produziert bekommen.
Die könnten sich tatsächlich von C Sharp,
was das angeht,
echt mal eine Riesenscheibe abschneiden.
Da sind auch genug Dinger,
wo ich mich frage, was macht Microsoft da?
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das ziemlich
konsistent gelöst.
Und es kommen auch sinnvolle Neuerungen rein.
Die dann auch sich gut integrieren.
Nicht einfach irgendwie...
Alte Pointer-Klasse ist scheiße.
Wir machen jetzt einfach zwei neue.
Oder...
Ja.
Unsere Default-String-Klasse sagt,
nehm doch irgendwie was anderes.
Oder...
Wir machen nur komplett
wirre Lambda-Syntax.
Oder was auch immer.
So ist halt C++.
Ja, man kann in C++ schon viel machen,
aber es ist halt einfach wirr und anstrengend.
Java ist nicht schlecht.
Ja, ich flame Java eigentlich bloß,
weil ich's witzig finde,
nicht weil ich's schlecht finde.
Java ist nicht schlecht.
Das einzig Schlechte an Java ist Oracle.
Also Microsoft hat mit .NET
echt 180 Grad Kehrtwende gemacht.
Mit ihrem Open-Source-Movement.
Und GitHub-Zeug da.
Also es kommt auch nicht von ungefähr,
dass .NET mittlerweile beliebter ist
wie jemals zuvor.
Was halt echt cool ist.
Ich mag .NET und C-Sharp.
Java flame wegen den Chinesen.
Ja, die Chinesen verwenden gerne Java.
Ja, gut.
Header-Files ist eh so ein Ding.
Das ist auch sowas.
Warum C++?
Es ist das Jahr 2021.
Warum
gibt es sowas
wie Header-Files überhaupt noch?
Was soll der Scheiß denn?
Guckt euch irgendeine x-beliebige Sprache
an, die die letzten
30 Jahre
rausgekommen ist.
Und guckt es euch ab.
Header-Files ist
eines der unsinnigsten Dinger,
das es heute immer noch gibt.
Denkt euch ein ordentliches
Modulformat aus.
Hat auch den Vorteil, dass
Entwicklertools einfacher zu basteln sind.
Ich meine die Autocompletion
für C++ ist ja sogar
in Visual Studio
kacke.
Ist in CLion kacke.
Also sprich, das sind die größten Dinger.
Der cute
Creator ist auch nicht so toll,
was das angeht, weil da blickt keiner
mehr durch.
Dann führt man sowas wie Auto ein.
Was ja eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee ist.
Es kann ja theoretisch
kein Auto in C++, sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr, als
war in C Sharp.
Ist aber von der Idee her das
ähnliche. Quasi ein Schlüsselwort, um
den Typ abzuleiten.
Und dann verkackt man das.
Dass man sich dann nicht mehr anzeigen
lassen kann, was für ein Typ eigentlich unten drunter ist.
Also
pfff
Ach, C++, Alter.
Lul.
Das ist so alt, das Netz ist schon Tradition.
Ja, die haben es ja versucht,
in irgendeinem der letzten C++-Standards
irgendwelche Module einzuführen. So haben sie es irgendwie nicht
geschafft. Weiß ich nicht, wie es da
aktuell aussieht.
Hast du auf deinem Staubsauger,
was, hast du auf deinem Staubsauger-Roboter jetzt noch
was extra drauflaufen, als fahrendes
Nass oder so?
Ne, das Ding kann nix. Ich wollte ja da mal
Minecraft drauflaufen lassen auf dem Staubsauger.
Ich sag euch Leute, Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger,
das wäre übelst viral gegangen
auf YouTube.
Leider läuft das nicht.
Das ist ein Ubuntu, glaube
1404 drauf.
Irgendeine
ARM-Architektur.
Du kriegst nichts gescheit nachinstalliert.
Und, ich mein,
512 RAM würden eigentlich reichen.
Ja, also,
es ging nicht. Also, was ich aktuell
auf meinem Staubsauger-Roboter drauflaufen hab,
ist das Webinterface.
Ja, Webinterface von Staubsauger-Roboter.
Karte vom
Wohnzimmer.
Ähm, sonst ist da nix
drauf, ne.
Tja.
Heutzutage
würden die wahrscheinlich einfach
alles, alles einkassieren.
Kann ja heute überall was drauf sein.
By the way, ich weiß, wie das
ist, bei der Hausdurchsuchung dabei zu
sein. Ich hatte selbst noch keine.
Aber mein Vater hatte schon eine.
Schon zwei.
Weil er, hab ich euch
ja mal erzählt, komische Dinger getrieben hat.
Also das, was ihr heute
auf YouTube in
Scam-Videos seht,
das hat mein Vater alles
Relive gemacht.
Und besser als die Scammer.
Den haben sie, den haben
sie nicht erwischt.
Also, die haben ihn erwischt, aber sie haben ihn nicht
dafür verurteilt bekommen, weil die Leute
freiwillig unterschrieben haben.
Der hat, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es euch schon mal
erzählt, aber der hatte
eine Partnervermittlung
in Frankfurt
und hat halt keine Partner vermittelt.
Ne, ne, ne, nicht die
Story. Der hatte, der hat eine
Partnervermittlungsagentur
aufgemacht und hat halt
Fake-Partner vermittelt.
Ähm, das lief dann, das lief dann so,
da kam irgendeine Oma, ich sag jetzt einfach mal
eine Oma, irgendeine ältere Frau, kam dann
hier hin, hat gemeint, oh, mein Mann ist gestorben
und sie sucht ja irgendwie immer noch nach jemandem
und da hat der, der einen Vertrag
aufgeschwätzt
und hat ihr dann auch Männer geschickt,
die angeblich von dieser Agentur sind
und auch Frauen suchen und das
waren halt alles gepriefte
äh, äh, äh, Leute
zum schöne Augen machen, die quasi dann
zu 20 Omas heimgefahren
sind und dort quasi, äh,
ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
verliebt vorgespielt haben, so dass
die Omas halt schön ihre, ihre
Vermittlungsbeiträge bezahlen.
Der hatte da so 5 Typen oder so
Der hat die richtig gescannt, Alter!
Der hat die richtig hardcore gescannt
und
das Witzige ist,
dass
es, die haben ihn ja auch
danach dann angezeigt
und der war ja, der war ja
sogar irgendwie mal ein halbes Jahr in Untersuchungshaft
oder so, da ging's, da ging's, damals ging's echt,
als ich klein war, ich hab das nur so am Rande mitbekommen,
also sprich, da ging's richtig rund
und
die haben ihn
die haben
ihn nichts dafür
äh, verurteilen
können, weil
die Verträge so gut geschrieben waren,
dass, dass
eigentlich dort drinne stand, dass es
ein Scam war, aber die Leute haben's trotzdem unterschrieben.
Ne, ne, da ist nichts
verjährt. Wie gesagt, die haben ihn ja versucht
deswegen, äh, zu erwischen.
Ja, und das ist
aber wie gesagt auch 30 Jahre her mittlerweile oder so.
Da war ich wirklich klein, wo's
da richtig zur Sache ging.
Und, oder 25 Jahre her, da war ich
wirklich noch klein und
es muss wohl so gewesen
sein, dass dann
paar von den Omas vor
Gericht ausgesagt haben und der
Richter muss die wohl wirklich wortwörtlich
gefragt haben, warum haben sie das
unterschrieben? Wie kann man
sowas unterschreiben?
Ey, also
mein Vater hat viel Scheiße gebaut, ja, ich hab mit
dem nicht, ich hab mit dem nicht so allzu
guten Kontakt, aber
das nehm ich ihm nicht
wirklich übel.
Da gehören zwei,
da gehören zwei Seiten dabei.
Ja, Scammer
und Leute, die sich scammen lassen, so wie, so wie
auf YouTube. Na, ich find's jetzt nicht geil,
Omas zu verarschen,
aber das hat mich jetzt persönlich
nicht so, nicht so getroffen. Der hat andere
Dinger getrieben, warum ich mit ihm nicht mehr allzu
viel zu tun haben will, ja, aber
deswegen nicht. Also,
der hat schon komische Dinger, das
stand, das stand damals auch irgendwo
in der Bild-Zeitung, da haben sie sich dann
drüber hergemacht.
Oh Mann.
Ich kann euch aber eins sagen, das ist echt,
das ist echt ein merkwürdiges Gefühl,
wenn ihr klein seid
und euer Vater sitzt im
Knast, beziehungsweise in
Untersuchungshaft, war er nicht wirklich im Knast.
Sie haben ja auch freigesprochen danach.
Ist aber echt komisches Gefühl,
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Meine Mutter
wollte mir das erst gar nicht erzählen.
wollte mir das damals erst gar nicht erzählen,
die hat immer gesagt, der ist im Urlaub.
Der ist im Urlaub.
Und ich hab gedacht, wo ist denn der Papa denn? Ja, der ist im Urlaub.
Und irgendwann hat sie
dann rausgerückt mit der Sprache, ja, okay,
da sitzt sie in Untersuchungshaft.
Tja, der hat sie gescampt.
Nee, aber der hat noch andere
Dinger getrieben, warum ich nichts mehr mit ihm zu tun
haben will, aber das nicht.
Weiß wer gerade
wie das Visual Studio Code Plugin
heißt, um Remote via SSH zu schreiben?
Keine Ahnung, aber nimm doch
SSHFS.
Da brauchst du es nicht mit Visual Studio zu machen.
SSHFS kannst du jetzt lokal
mounten. Ja.
Bisschen wie die
Raubkopierwerbung, ja.
Ja und wie ich da ursprünglich drauf
gekommen bin, deswegen gab es bei uns schon
mal eine Hausdurchsuchung.
Meine Mutter hat sich ja damals schon von ihm getrennt
und die waren dann bei uns in der
Wohnung, haben da durchsucht, ob da nicht noch
irgendwelche Beweise zu finden sind gegen
meinen Vater. Und später
hat er dann auf Ebay mal irgendwelche
irgendwelche
Scamdinger versucht
und da haben sie nochmal durchsucht.
Also eins muss man sagen,
also mein Vater hat sich nicht gerade
mit Ruhm bekleckert, was das angeht.
Jetzt ist er bestimmt im
Scalper Business. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, was der gerade macht. Ich will es auch gar nicht wissen.
Gibt es eine Alternative
zu C++, weil man ESP
2 und 3 programmieren will? Ne, nicht wirklich.
Es gibt zwar MicroPython
und es gibt auch irgendwie eine Rust-Tool-Chain,
aber das ist alles Mist. Also
wirklich gut. Hat er ein
Gewerbe mit der Dating-Sache angemeldet?
Bestimmt.
Der hatte sogar
ein relativ großes Büro in
Frankfurt.
In einem relativ hohen, das weiß ich noch,
das fand ich damals übelst geil,
dort aus dem Hochhaus
zu gucken. Klar hat er das.
Der hatte ja auch Mitarbeiter.
Das war ja gar nicht, die Firma war gar nicht
so klein. Da hatte er ja irgendwie auch
20 Leute oder so.
Ne, mein Vater ist jetzt,
wie alt ist denn der jetzt?
72 oder so.
Der scammt
heute nicht mehr so viele Leute. Wobei, der probiert es
wahrscheinlich noch, aber es klappt mit 72 nicht mehr so.
Ja.
Ne, aber in der Richtung
habe ich echt gar nichts von meinem Vater.
Also geerbt
meine ich jetzt, ja. Also so an
Charakterzügen in der Richtung
gar nichts.
Daher kommt deine Liebe für C++.
Plus, ja.
Hat der was mit Wirecard
zu tun? Nein, Quatsch.
Das ist doch alles schon viel älter gewesen.
Im Prinzip war das auch nichts
großes Internationales. Das war halt hier
was in Frankfurt. Das war ja noch pre-Internet.
Letztendlich machen das aber,
zwar ohne Scheiß, ne,
ich könnte wetten, viele
Dating-Seiten machen das heute nicht anders.
Da wird auch gescampt, was
das Zeug hält, sodass es nicht gemerkt wird.
Da war, ne, Kobol war da nicht neu.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
das muss irgendwie
1990 oder so
gewesen sein, 1995 spätestens.
Heute läuft's
genauso, ja. Da wird genauso
auf ähnliche Art und Weise gescampt. Deswegen,
es ist ja so, die Scams,
die heute im Internet durchgezogen werden,
das sind eigentlich
Oldschool-Scams.
Ja?
Die gibt's teilweise schon lange.
Auch diese Möchtegern-Guru-Berater
und so, was es da alles gibt, gibt's schon ewig.
Da ist nicht so viel Neues
dabei. Das Medium hat sich halt geändert.
Heute ist es, komm in die Gruppe.
Früher war's
halt irgendwas anderes. Aber im Prinzip ist es
der gleiche Scheiß.
Und die Leute sind damals drauf
reingefallen, fallen heute drauf rein.
Tja. Leute, ich glaub,
ich geh jetzt off. Ja, ich geh jetzt off.
Und vielleicht bin ich morgen direkt
wieder am Start. Wenn ich erstmal ein bisschen
Streaming-Streak habe,
dann muss da aufrechterhalten werden.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht's
gut. Bis denn. See you.